you can take seemingly an average person
and you can turn them into something
extraordinary and if you take an
extraordinary person what you will find
is that they have gone through some kind
of process to make them that way you're
always using the instrument of yourself
and once you start teaching people those
things you see an astronomical
Improvement in basically like all
dimensions of their life happiness
Income Life satisfaction studied to
become a monk trained and taught at
Harvard Medical School I'm a clinician
I've done Neuroscience research can you
cure depression
the scientific answer
[Music]
is thank you very much Dr K Alo or
healthy gamer GG youve came on the iced
coffee Hour podcast you do these things
where you psychoanalyze other massive
creators you've done it for like lwig
you've done it for xqc who else you've
done it for Destiny for all of these
people and they are so fascinating and
I'm noticing amongst like those Ultra
successful people they are uniquely
special or different in the way that
their brain works have you noticed this
I mean so all these people are outliers
but I I think the the really interesting
thing is that you know when I talk to
these people and for the record I don't
psychoanalyze them like psychoanalysis
is like four hours a week for like years
and years and years that's really what
psychoanalysis is but I think that if
you look at like generally speaking
human beings we share a lot like the
fundamental nature of the way that our
mind works the way that our brain works
like we all basically have the same
parts of the brain all the parts of the
brain do the same things and in some
people the activity levels of different
parts of their being their personality
their brain call it whatever you want to
are just at different places right and
so that's what really creates an outlier
I mean there may be some genetic
differences of course but I think
generally speaking my experience has
been overwhelmingly that you can take
seemingly an average person and you can
turn them into something extraordinary
and if you take an extraordinary person
um what you will find is that they have
gone through some kind of to process to
make them that way and like that was the
experience of like my life like
absolutely so they just weren't born as
an extraordinary person I mean so it
depends on how you define extraordinary
so like you can look at IQ for example
and you can say like all these people
prob probably have super high IQs but
like there are a lot of people in
society who have the same level of IQ
that like let's say streamers have or or
people who are very successful um and
interestingly enough there's even some
data that suggests that high IQ on on
the whole correlates with like success
up until a point but if you're very very
high IQ there's some evidence that
suggests that it's actually very hard to
be successful is that why uh gifted kids
are often special needs that was one of
your most viewed videos yeah so this was
something that blew my mind when I was
in residency training I had a supervisor
one time that told me that like you know
gifted kids are like special needs kids
and that kind of blew my mind and I
asked her like what do you mean by that
and so she started explaining this to me
and then I sort of realized and I
realized that this is what had happened
to me so if you think about a child
who's gifted right so let's say that
you're in like the top one or 2% of IQ
um the first thing to understand is that
your experience of school is going to be
very different right so kids who are
very smart literally have needs that are
different from the average kid so if we
look at academics so the school moves at
the pace of the slowest child right if
we look at our school system what's it
designed to do schools are not places
where we take kids and we try to have
them live up to their fullest potential
kids are places if you look at like the
mandates around schools it's about like
leaving no child behind so the system is
is sort of designed to take the worst
performing kids and kind of like make
sure they're doing okay so if we look at
like special education at schools what
is special education for it's for the
kids who are struggling not the kids who
are bored and this is what tends to
happen with kids who are super smart is
that they get bored with school um I
remember when I was like in the first
grade I you know my math teacher gave me
a worksheet and she was like here's the
worksheet and so I did the worksheet and
I walked up to her and I said here I
like 10 minutes later I gave it to her
and I was like can I have the next one
and she's like what do you mean the next
one this is what we're doing today and
so school is incredibly boring and then
what tends to happen is that these kids
start to like flounder in a lot of ways
they get distracted in a lot of ways
they become uninvested in education the
other problem that they run into is that
if you're a kid who does really well in
school and you're not challenged you
don't develop study habits so this is a
really common problem where what happens
is you're at the top of your class in
the first grade second grade third grade
fourth grade fifth grade sixth grade
seventh grade you hit high school and
now suddenly you need to study and you
haven't developed any study habits and
you literally do not know how to study
so what you'll see is this like tanking
of GPA for kids who have high IQ as they
reach the natural point where their int
their raw intellect is no longer
sufficient for like learning calculus
right and so these are the kinds of
needs that kids have that we don't sort
of recognize um when they've got high IQ
there's also other kinds of data so if
you look at like uh the the rate of
depression so if you look at the
prevalence of depression about 99.5% of
people on a given day will be depressed
if you look at people who are in the top
2% in terms of IQ it's
36.6 and so it's like staggering that
like you know
these kids while they're gifted in many
ways we sort of think about IQ as just
sort of a straight positive which I
think if you have an environment that is
conducive to it it probably is but
taking a smart kid and putting him into
an average world is something that is
like oftentimes very very difficult yeah
do you think that homeschooling is a
solution to
that I mean it could be but you're we
have to presume that the people who are
doing the homeschooling know how to
provide for the special needs of of the
kid who's super smart right sure one
thing that I think is rare that
shouldn't be so rare is kids moving up
and going down in grades because I was
just talking to my brother's friend who
went up four grades in elementary school
and he said because he was so bored that
he like you said couldn't develop those
study habits because he wouldn't need to
study for those exams because he could
rely on his raw intelligence and then
once he went up four grades he actually
fit the general like IQ of the or not
the IQ of but like you know he would
need to study the the same amount as the
other his peers and it had actually
ended up really positively affecting him
for the rest of his life whereas other
people it really hurt don't you think
that maybe there's some social issues
that affect you though if you skip too
far ahead and you can't relate to your
peers and maybe you feel like maybe
you're a bit of an outsider like the
kids that go to college like at 16 yeah
so I mean my brother went to college at
16 so like he's one of those kids and I
think there's definitely some kind of
price to be paid but let's think about
the Baseline so how many kids who go to
college at 18 fit in right like I'd say
maybe 50% sure so absolutely there are
social changes that there are additional
social pressures um and we kind of see
this with homeschooling right so a lot
of parents who will homeschool will be
super careful about creating a positive
social environment so they're involved
with like extracurriculars and sports
and things like that um so I I think
that it's a fair assumption to say that
this person is going to have some kinds
of social difficulties but I think the
biggest thing to kind of consider there
is that these kids will be viewed
differently right so they'll have some
kind of because you've got a 16-year-old
who's hanging out with 18year olds or in
the case of your friend I mean four
years is a lot you've got like a
13-year-old who's just hitting puberty
who's in grades with like 17y olds right
and that's like that's really
challenging in a lot of ways for sure is
IQ genetic and if it isn't how is that
something that you could necessarily
measure accurately like are IQ tests are
they do they work uh so there is a part
of IQ that is inheritable so there's a
portion of it that is absolutely genetic
um you know we're probably talking about
somewhere between like 50 and 70% is my
guess uh I think we're pretty good at
measuring IQ but the key thing is like
it's not like take our IQ test on the
internet that's what I did same um and
so if if you really look at it like real
IQ testing done by like a neuros
pychology or a psychologist is is like
kind of hard to get access to like I
think it it's a test that takes maybe
even a couple of hours and it's sort of
like very standardized and stuff like
that the validity of it also depends on
it not being publicly available so
people can't like practice for the test
so I think IQ is a pretty valid
construct I think the problem with IQ is
that we use it a sub as a substitute for
all of these other important constructs
that most people ignore like EQ is at
the top of the list there where if you
look at actually like success in life EQ
correlates more highly with success than
IQ does what are the differences between
the two so EQ is emotion quo and I kind
of think about it as being broken up
into a couple different pieces so this
is stuff like selfawareness
um emotional regulation skills um even
things like empathy and being able to
develop relationships so these are all
parts of like EQ and a really good
example of this is you can look at so
what do you all think the average income
is for the top 2% of the population top
2% of income earners probably 400 Grand
I would say 500 Grand % oh is it higher
no no go go ahead I was going to say the
world or the US uh I think this is us us
yeah I would say probably 4 to 500 is my
350 yeah so yall are in the ballpark
right so I think it's somewhere I don't
remember if it was 250 or 400 kind of
depends a little bit on it's actually
perfect like somewhere around 300 350
which just means you know they're all
kind of like Finance Bros so spot on my
answer is a little closer than Jack's
though it actually was not if we rewind
we rewind the tape we'll see four to 500
is my guess 350 while we're taking
guesses Graham guess how much this super
nice super fancy espresso machine would
cost you I don't know it's pretty nice
200 bucks if you went with a traditional
retailer that would be the cost but with
today's sponsor sonic power you can get
really high quality electronics for just
a fraction of the cost for example this
espresso machine 120 bucks lest how does
that work so basically sonic power cuts
out the middleman that drives the prices
of electronics up they go right to the
supplier and sell directly to the
customer which allows them to keep the
quality High and the prices low that's
actually really cool it's really
interesting what else do they have well
also have an ice maker that you can use
to make iced coffee oh that sounds so
good they also just have a bunch of
other stuff that are perfect for
Christmas gifts such as their dys and
dupe hair dryer their mini massage gun
electric wine opener and so much more
see I don't see the point in spending
more money than you actually have to on
a product if you're able to cut off the
middleman and save money why not do it
it's fantastic and Graham did I mention
there's free shipping you will never pay
for shipping at Sonic power and I guess
if you thought if the products weren't
affordable enough we've got an even
better offer for you just visit Sonic
power. that's
doco.com doco and use the code iced for
20% off your order again that's Sonic
power. Co use code IC and you get 20%
off your entire order thank you sonic
power for sponsoring today's video and
now let's get back to the podcast so now
let me ask youall a question what do you
think the top 2% youall know what Mena
is yeah what do yall think the top 2% of
Mena earns a year oh my guess is
probably I'm guessing it's going to be a
surprising you absolutely data point so
I'm going to say probably like 90 150
for me 100 so top 2% of Mena spot on
actually earns like 25 to 30% of what
top 2% of the total population but my
guess is because a lot of those people
are more on academics or maybe they need
something that's so just like mentally
stimulating that those those fields
don't pay as much as the people who
maybe are getting into like sales so
possible right so there's all kinds of
interpretations of the data that we need
to be careful about
um but I think a big reason for that is
like think about who joins Mensa right
so like a lot of times this isn't a dig
on Mena but like people who are
utilizing their intelligence in a active
way in the world oftentimes don't have
time for Mena and a lot of times people
will join Mena at a young age but I
think the key thing about Mena is that
you know it goes back to this idea of
like IQ is like a gifted kid with
special needs where they run into these
problems like a lot of super smart kids
that I work with you know they run into
these problem problems where they like
don't develop study habit so then when
it comes to college and Landing a job or
they're socially isolated they're more
prone to things like depression um and
if you think about you know how do you
make 400 Grand like networking is a huge
part of it self-awareness is a huge part
of it knowing when to keep your mouth
shut and when to talk um being able to
regulate your emotions is a huge part of
it so I think that what you probably
need to be successful is like some
minimum level of IQ and it probably
scales some as you get smarter and
smarter and smarter but what I've seen
the most transformation because IQ is
relatively fixed is teaching people EQ
skills so as you teach people more about
themselves and how they function as
human beings right because like at the
end of the day it doesn't matter what
you do you're always using the
instrument of yourself and we never get
formal training about why can't I wake
up in the morning right why do I like
coffee why do I get dependent on coffee
why do I get dependent on pornography
why do I feel the way that I do why do I
feel uncomfortable presenting in front
of my bosses like there's all kinds of
stuff about you as an instrument that we
never learn and once you start teaching
people those things you see an
astronomical Improvement in basically
like all dimensions of their life
happiness Income Life
satisfaction like Financial stuff so how
do you go about analyzing that for
yourself or do you think that you would
need someone else's help to kind of get
that information out of you to like work
on that you can actually figure out in
my opinion you can figure out most most
of the stuff by yourself it's just
probably going to take you a lot longer
so the first thing is that you know
before I went to med school in residency
I spent about 7 years starting to become
a monk and that was like transformative
for me and what I really loved about it
is like I was struggling in school so I
basically like I was a smart kid I was
you know I jumped a grade um and then
like was doing fine in school until I
kind of hit high school and college and
then I started like failing out of
college because like it was just getting
straight FS I I I was one of these
gifted kids who didn't learn how to
study and so one of the things that
really frustrated me is like I knew what
I needed to do right so like I just need
to wake up every day and like I need to
go to Spanish class at 8: a.m. and I
have trouble waking up so then the next
semester I was like okay like let me get
a 8 a.m. Spanish class that way it'll
force me to wake myself up and if I
force myself to wake myself up at 8:
a.m. then like my day will be productive
so I tried all these intellectual
techniques to analyze my life and try to
figure out like how I should optimize
things but the basic problem is that
like this thing
did not listen to this right so I I knew
what I needed to do I just couldn't
bring myself to do it and what I really
found when I went to India and I was
like failing out of college and my dad
was like we've tried everything like I
look you need to go to India right so
he's like and I was like all right fine
whatever what does that mean he says
Alec you just need to go to India you're
like Dad I've tried everything I'm
getting FS you got to go to India son
how is India going to like straighten
you out it's a great question so I'm
Indian yeah so you know my family is
lucky enough it's my karma to have this
kind of background and my parents are
wonderful people and they tried
everything so like as I started failing
they tried to tried tough love they
tried um you know they they sent me to
see a psychologist like they kind of
tried everything under the sun and
nothing was working and so like I think
they understood that there is a
knowledge about the self in the East
that is very powerful compared to the
west and if youall want to understand
that the simple thing to understand is
that all of of our scientific
understanding about you Neuroscience
psychology whatever none of it actually
applies to you it's all population based
so when we say like do you all get that
yes right so so this is the for the
average VI I think proba so this is the
thing that's kind of confusing for
people so if I say that like let's say
ssris or anti-depressant medications are
30% effective for
depression does that mean that if I give
you an anti-depressant medication and
you are press you will get 30% better
absolutely not so what we do in Western
science is we take 10,000 people and we
give them something like we'll give them
let's say anti-depressant medication and
then we'll see on
average what's the Improvement so what
you really need to understand is amongst
those 10,000 people there are actually
10,000 individual responses to these
medications and then what we do is we
average all these together and then we
kind of say this is what's right so the
best example of this is like do you all
know where we got 2,000 calorie diet any
idea probably just the average person
right absolutely so it has nothing to do
with science nothing to do with
metabolism nothing to do with physiology
nothing to do with carbs or keto or any
of that stuff it's not scientific at all
literally what we did there's this thing
called the enhan study and what we did
is we asked Americans do you have any
health problems and they said no and
then we said okay for all the people who
have no health problems how many
calories a day do you eat and then we
literally average that number and this
became a recommendation so if we use the
system for fashion right what would be
our recommendation we're going to take
what you're wearing we're going to take
what I'm wearing we're going to find
three random women on the street we're
going to we're going to take all those
pieces of clothing we're going to
average them together and everyone's
going to wear like a gray smok right
that's our recommendation so a big thing
that a lot of people don't realize is
that Western medicine is not
individualized and this is precisely why
you can read a paper on Neuroscience
let's say you read a paper paper on
Neuroscience that says willpower
correlates with success and then what do
you do with that like I read that paper
and then do I get better at willpower
like there's no there's no subjectivity
to it so in the East the way that they
learned about their mind was very
different they started with me and only
me I don't care about anybody else how
does this instrument work from a
subjective standpoint and this is why
the West I mean the East developed
meditation because someone sat down and
was like how do I control my mind how do
I calm myself down what is the technique
that works so what we see in Western
science is that we're very deficient in
techniques we know everything about the
science of Charisma and the science of
willpower and the science of memory but
have we figured out what's the best way
to learn have we figured out what's the
best way to boost willpower you know
what the answer is what's what's the one
practice that we have that boosts
willpower in memory boosts willpower and
meditation absolutely right and they
figured that crap out 6,000 years ago
10,000 Years Ago by some estimates
without a single scientific study
because they looked at what actually
works for an individual not what works
for a population and that's what where
we are in the west and it's great I mean
Western medicine isn't bad right I'm a
medical doctor and it's good in a lot of
ways because if we look at something
like cholesterol medication if I'm
seeing a 100 patients and I want like
this population to die less of heart
attacks I can give them cholesterol
medication it'll improve the health of
the population as a whole but there's no
individuality to it and so this is where
I think that like what my dad kind of
circling back to the point at hand is he
sort of recognized that like what I
needed was like something that can be
taught in India like I need I don't know
exactly what he understood but he kind
of said like hey this is what you need
because they tried everything else so
you just need to go and for once in my
life I just like listened to him I
didn't know what I was getting myself
into I didn't know what I was going to
do there I didn't know but I know that I
had tried everything that I needed to
try and like nothing was working so I
needed something drastic and that it
certainly was okay so you you go to
India you arrive
what is what happens did they just send
you to like a camp or something you have
family in there that you stay with or
how does this work great great questions
okay so the the first thing to
understand is I've been to India a ton
of times but I went to a part of India
that I've never been before don't know
anyone don't speak the language how much
did you know going into this nothing you
just showed up in IND I just showed up
he said you need to go we booked a plane
ticket for 10 days and then I hopped on
what is like like okay I'm wondering as
a kid my dad says Jack you have to go to
the Homeland you're going to Wales and
I'm like okay I know nothing about Wales
they send me off to Wales I
arrive then what I'll I'll tell
literally what happened okay so I I this
this conversation with my dad is at 2:
a.m. it's in our living room okay and
the reason we're having this
conversation is it's the end of my
sophomore year it's my second year on
academic probation I'm on the verge of
failing out of college or I've already
sort of failed out and it's like if I
continue failing they're going to kick
me out okay then my we've tried
everything he's tried yelling it for the
last 3 years we've been having like
heart-to-heart talks and trying to
problem solve and whatever so we're both
like we're we just both resigned we're
like this is screwed right this is just
not working so then he just says you
need to go to India that's like that's
what it was you know what while we're on
that topic we talk a lot about financial
success here on the channel but what's
even more important is the mental health
along the way so in today's sponsor
better help reached out I actually
signed up myself for a few different
sessions and my therapist gave me some
really helpful insight that I had never
heard of before that really helped me
understand my ADHD so I got a lot of
answers as to why I do the things the
way that I do and also the most
mind-blowing was actually how it
impacted My Life as a child but then I
learned how I can use my ADHD to my
advantage and it was super easy to use
you could talk to your therapist by text
chat phone or video call and you can
even message your therapist at any time
or schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you better help is the
world's largest therapy service used by
over 4 million people and with over
30,000 licensed therapists within their
Network and if for any reason your
therapist is in the right fit you can
get a whole new therapist for no
additional cost to get started all you
need to do is fill out a questionnaire
to assess your specific needs and in
most cases you'll get matched with the
therapist in 48 hours or less so if
you're interested in getting started
with betterhelp check out betterhelp.com
IED coffee hour or use the link Down
Below in the description to get 10% off
your first month of therapy again the
link is down below in the description to
get 10% off your first month of therapy
thank you so much to betterhelp for
sponsoring today's podcast and now let's
get back to the episode so I get on a
plane I go to the airport and I land in
Bangalore and then like I don't have a
phone number I don't know what's going
on like I don't like this was like back
before cell phones were a thing this is
2003 okay so like I'm sitting there and
I was like well [__] like I don't know
what can I yeah tell story okay so I'm
like sitting there right and then this
like finally like you know I know I
don't know if you guys know but you know
when you go out to of the airport you
walk out of the baggage claim there's a
bunch of people waiting for you like
your family's waiting for then they wave
they're like oh my God right so like
everyone leaves and then there's one guy
waiting there and I walk up to him and
I'm like are are you here for to pick
someone up and he's
like yes okay and I'm like are you here
to pick up all and he's like
okay and I'm like do you speak English
and he's like
okay and so I was like are you here to
pick me up and he's like okay and so I
didn't know who this guy was he was
waiting for someone and I'm the last
person there so I get in a car with him
and then we're in the car get in this
van and then we're in this van for like
2 hours and we clearly like we leave the
city and we're driving out of the hills
there's like no light okay and then like
we we like Drive there's a gate there's
a guy at a gate the guy opens the gate
we drive through this is like 2 and a
half hours in it's like a bumpy road
there's I can't see anything there the
power had gone out okay so then like
they they like walk me to a place and
then like this lady comes out and she's
like you know oh hi Alo you know like I
know your father really well I'm Dr
nagaratna and so I was like cool okay
thank God I I came to the right place
they show me to my room it's about
midnight maybe 12:30 so I like brush my
teeth I change I go to sleep super bare
room I I don't know if you guys have
even seen like you know like poor
conditions and developing it's not like
poor but you know it's like super simple
kind of like old school like clay floor
single window um you know fan that
doesn't work like very simple bed so I
go to sleep and then suddenly I'm awoken
by the sound of a bell and then I'm like
what the and I hear this Bell like
someone's ringing this Bell and I look
outside I see the moon like what is
going on here so I I'm kind of like is
something wrong so I think that there's
a fire or something because it sounds
like a fire alarm and I step outside and
I hear people moving in the rooms but no
one seems panicked so I'm like I don't
know what this is but let me just I
guess I'm going to get dressed because I
hear people I hear toilets flushing and
whatnot so I get dressed and then I kind
of wander outside it's like 4:30 in the
morning the moon's up next thing that I
hear
is I'm like what the what was that and
then I hear it
again and then I hear like literally 50
or 60 people like vomiting and then I
walk out and then I see like in the
Moonlight there's a ditch and there's
about 50 people lying up and there's a
handful of people walking behind them
and all of these people are vomiting
copious amounts of stuff into the ditch
and I'm like oh my god what have I
walked into is this like the plague am I
going to die turns out that there's this
yogic practice called
vandi when vandi is a practice that you
do where you drink like a gallon of
isotonic water so salt water and then
you vomit it up and it turns out that
this this practice probably has a ton of
health benefits hasn't been studied very
well but is really good for like
allergies and things like that you know
I can't recommend that as a medical
doctor because we don't we don't have
the data but that's just one of and I'm
like oh my God what is this place and so
turns out that nothing was wrong and
that this is just a yogic cleansing
practice um or should the practice which
like helps you you know clean out your
like lungs and your stomach and like all
this other kind of stuff um and I sounds
shocking and so what I discovered in
India was that was my experience of what
I walked into actually so I think I was
answering a question okay so so couple
things how were you not just horrified
because I was horrified I would not
trust getting into a car with a guy that
couldn't speak my language I didn't even
know if I was picked up by the right guy
he drives for 2 hours in a
in the middle of nowhere I wouldn't I
would just I would call my dad and be
like Dad is this the guy like send him a
photo of the guy like are you sure
there's no cell phone a landline there's
got to be a pay phone somewhere but you
just how were so so even just getting in
the car with this guy maybe times were
different back then when you say let's
understand something forget about times
it's not about times it's about me and
you okay yes let's here okay so when you
say you're terrified yes terrified of
what losing my life getting kidnapped
your life is worth something Yes mine
wasn't well
right like to be honest okay so were you
like depressed in things or was it I'm
sure like take your pick bro of whatever
mental state that is negative you with
like I was going no dude I was someone
who was a smart kid failing out of
college um you know the the the town
that I grew up in five out of five
Indian kids that were in my grade in the
whole city three of them became
doctors right so like super high
expectations
like failing at life miserably trying
everything that I knew because I'm a
smart kid I'm supposed to be what what
what was I what did I have what was
worth losing nothing I had nothing worth
losing that makes sense so you're here
at this place how does this change your
perspective what do they do how do they
start so the first two weeks I'm crying
every
day um every day I get on the phone and
I call from a a pay phone right so they
have like a pay phone like one pay phone
in the ashro and like I'm on the verge
of telling my dad like send s me a
ticket I want to come home I hate it
here like I can't eat anything I've got
like all kinds of GI problems from like
stress related stuff and things like
that so I'm like on the verge of
vomiting it's boring there we're doing a
bunch of yoga and we're like learning
some meditation techniques but it
doesn't really do anything for me and
then so for for the first two weeks like
I hate it I hate it I hate it and then
what I I remember like I even remember
the daily phone calls and thinking to
myself like I'm going to tell them like
to send me a ticket and I want to come
home and then over the course of that
phone call I'm kind of like choking back
tears and I just I say like not today
like I'm not going to like cave today I
can always get a ticket tomorrow I can
last like one more day and I it was also
like a ton of Shame it's not like pride
and like perseverance it's like shame
it's like I can't even do this like I'm
going to call my Daddy and say like send
me a ticket like I've washed out of this
to I couldn't handle the shame of it and
then what started to happen is I made
one particular friend who's probably the
closest thing to a guru that I've had
but he was actually another student in
the asham and um then I started like he
we would go on a walk every day and like
we would just talk for about an hour and
a half and I was just blown away by like
what this person understood like he
started like helping me understand
things about myself I was like you know
we were talking a little bit and I think
he also understood that I needed help
right so he started to steer the
conversation in particular ways where I
would ask him questions so like one day
for example like he brought me a book
and he's like hey I think you should
definitely like read you know these
particular chapters and then we'd talk
what book was it um I think this one was
Kundalini Tantra I'll try to
Google search that I it's not a book I
would recommend people read um is say
yoga or no what is sure okay we can talk
about what yoga is if youall want but in
the Eastern system of of you know but
this Kundalini Tantra is more tantric
than yogic so tantric you guys are
familiar with that term tantric sex is
usually what people talk there's a
there's a tantric a thric technique to
have a prolonged period of um sexual
activity without orgasm edging is what
you're saying It's Kind well so no it's
not actually so it's not edging it's not
edging no no because actually
technically it's not edging I'm just
trying to understand no no so what it is
actually it's way better than edging so
much better than edging this is the
beauty between the East and the West got
it so in the west what we do is we Edge
right and what is edging it is delaying
orgasms so you build up that internal
frustration so that when you finally
ejaculate then it feels really good
right that's edging yeah yeah so the
thrix do it way better they have orgasm
without ejaculation an orgasm doesn't
end until ejaculation happens so they're
able to have orgasms for like 40 minutes
at a stretch you're kidding no that's
what sex sex is Graham wants to know how
you do this so
badly
so I mean so this is this is where like
how to do it use it on for the average
person listening just for the average
person it's not something to be done oh
yeah so I I would not recommend it why
cuz then you just I mean you give up on
other all other things in life the only
joy you
have all I need is this so the key thing
to understand about I guess we're
talking about thrixxx now um so here's
the key thing to understand so all
meditation is designed to elevate your
Consciousness to a certain level okay
now everyone's like what does that mean
like oh like let's like Elevate our
energies to like no so I want youall to
think about
your life right so like right now how do
you feel how do I feel yeah I feel
amazing right now incredible I'm like
super happy okay I'm a seven maybe six
and a half seven like are you saying gen
like
generally in this moment honestly I
would say I'm like a nine and a half I'm
so happy why I'm because I have so many
questions about psychology just general
philosophical questions and stuff like
that and I feel like I can learn a a lot
from you and these are questions I've
had ever since I was a kid okay so what
is your mind doing right now well
generally speaking I would say 85% of
time is very present and just listening
to what you have to say and then there's
other 15% of the the time you know so
one in seven seconds I'm like kind of
just like thinking about something else
and it's like oh I wonder about this and
then you're saying something and I'm
applying that to my own life when did I
do this okay let's understand a couple
things okay so what do youall think is
the correlation you said you're 85%
focused right so what is the correlation
between the of focus and how good you
feel about yourself I would say higher
Focus feel
better never thought of it before okay
right like when you get into a okay so
rule number one of this discussion
because this is what we're doing now you
are not allowed to site anything okay
okay we're going to learn 100% from our
own internal experience okay because who
the [__] knows if the flow state is even
a real thing like who knows like it
could be a conspiracy we don't know
science could disprove it a year from
now right that's what science is really
good at we disprove stuff all the time
time okay so let's let's talk with
graham for a second so Graham if you
sort of think about the happiest moments
in your life like it doesn't have to be
like the birth of your kids or anything
like that but like think about those
moments where you just feel the best
yeah what can you give me an example
usually I'm working on something I'm
really excited about usually those are
the moments that uh like the flow state
for me which is time to stops and all of
a sudden okay okay hold on so now we're
getting into a couple good things
so let's talk about time stopping what
is the quality of the Mind what is the
mind doing when time is going it's
occupied something okay so let's let's
talk about when time is moving super
slow the opposite of stopping right what
kind of thoughts do you have when when
your mind is like oh my God this is
taking forever neurotic thoughts
repetitive thoughts just like running
through right so you're thinking when is
this going to end oh my God you're
thinking about this and then you're
thinking about this and you're thinking
about this so this is the first thing to
understand the level of focus of the
mind correlates with happiness okay and
if we think about when we're
unhappy and also we have to have mind
active to notice the presence of time
that's the other thing you'll get that
and it sounds kind of weird but is our
mind active when we sleep kind of I mean
no I mean like dreams from that yeah
right so no Neuroscience okay we talk
about REM sleep and sleep unconsciously
active but how do you know that dreams
is that unconscious I would say so you I
don't think you I don't think you
necessarily control your just sometimes
a dream dream do you control your
thoughts
uh sometimes no I don't I feel like a
lot of thoughts are just unconscious
thoughts that bubble up I don't really
would say the majority of thoughts we
don't control right right if we could if
it was the default state of human beings
to control their thoughts any human on
the planet could pick up a chemistry
textbook and read it from cover to cover
we do not control our mind our mind
controls us okay so let's kind of go
back to the task at hand which is
understanding the nature of Mind Time
Focus happiness all this crap so first
thing to understand is that the
more distracted mind is the more you're
going to be aware of time the less
focused mind is the less you will be
aware of time and sleep is a great
example so sleep is like a state of
essentially no mind except when we dream
sure we'll get to that maybe that's kind
of a tangent but so the first thing to
understand is that the activity of the
mind correlates with the perception of
time and so when we enter something like
a flow State the perception of time
disappears the other thing that's
happening in a flow state is we have
focused mind so if you sort of think
about let's talk about like not being
able to enjoy dinner let's say I'm going
to dinner with y'all okay and we're like
having fun but if my mind is not focused
on the dinner and I keep on thinking
about oh my God these guys are going to
ask me to teach them how to do dri sex
and that's only a problem because I only
want to teach one of them how am I going
to fix this right so the more distracted
my mind is the less I enjoy the present
moment with me so now let's talk about
orgasm what happens when you come to
your mind go ahead Graham waiting for
you Jack the moment of orgasm is really
powerful from a Consciousness standpoint
because your mind becomes completely
one-pointed that's why it feels so damn
good so if you look at human beings what
do you gravitate towards you gravitate
towards things that bring your mind to
one-pointedness I'm walking on down the
beach and there's a Sunset and I'm not
thinking about anything I'm just there
right and I'm absorbed in the experience
of the present or I'm whitewater rafting
and when I'm whitewater rafting I'm just
there I I literally cannot afford to
think about anything else and the
interesting thing about orgasm is orgasm
is one of the very few physiologic
techniques that automatically induce
complete focus of the mind right and
even if we look at people like there's
if you look at people who have like
sexual difficulties right so anorgasmia
or difficulties with desire and stuff
like that someone who has anxiety and
has difficulty maintaining an erection
it all makes sense right because now we
understand that if sex is about present
and focus and orgasm is one-pointedness
but I am anxious I'm thinking is my
partner enjoying it are they not
enjoying it blah blah blah then I don't
enjoy it it's difficult for me to attain
that one-pointed state so sex and orgasm
specifically is essentially a meditation
technique and all meditation techniques
are designed to bring our mind
originally to one-pointedness and then
transcend mind entirely the activity of
Mind completely
stops and we still retain awareness
which is something that very few people
actually most people have probably
experienced it but it's like in in
glimpses here or there and like maybe
like whitewater rafting is a good
example where there are times where in a
flow State your mind is still active
usually but there are times where youall
will hopefully have had in your life
where like literally your mind had no
thoughts but you were still awake and
fully present is that that ever happened
to y'all mhmh outside of orgasm yes
examples pickle
ball right like a ping pong too like you
just get into that Groove where you're
just doing those forehand forehand
forehand forehand and the ball is just
like bouncing you're kind of listening
to it you talking about ping pong or
masturbation uh
pingpong uh yeah I haven't experienced
masturbation of course but yeah in ping
pong yeah you just get into that flow
state where you just like just keep the
ball on the table right so so then like
if you think about it you're not even
having thoughts no and even I would even
say so this is the cool thing about
meditation is as you transcend mind you
also transcend ego which is like oh my
god let's transcend the ego it's not
anything so mystical so you become one
with the pickle ball you know what I
mean like you lose yourself you stop
being this guy muscle memory like your
body's kind of controlling you your body
is controlling and even your mind is on
autopilot and you're just present and if
I were to if I were to ask you like you
know like you'd forget about your
haircut you'd forget about everything
you're just one with the pickle ball and
so this is the goal of meditation is is
to attain these states of mind and the
reason that they do thric sex is because
during that sustained state of orgasm
it's not about pleasure so this is why I
say that y'all are not ready for it okay
because it's powerful stuff y'all are
playing with fire here and and um so
what what we really want to achieve is
it's a tool that's used to sustain that
state of mind for an extended period of
time by powerfully harnessing your
physiology that makes a lot of sense and
I I think it explains why I like pickle
ball so much and why Graham likes work
so much because he always says like when
he's working I ask him like why does he
like it he's like why just get into this
Flow State I know I'm not supposed to
use that term but where that's all he's
thinking about and anytime I break him
from that or like we be in there talking
about a title thumbnail and I'll hear
like and Macy walks in like no he
doesn't say that to his fiance but you
could tell like he just wants to be in
that state of like that is all he's
focusing on yeah so if you kind of look
at it so this is the thing about
meditation is we as human beings some of
us figure out how to attain
one-pointedness of the mind that a lot
of human beings will figure out right
and the key thing to understand about
meditation is that it's a state I mean
not meditation but what we're going for
is a state of consciousness and there
are many ways to attain that State of
Consciousness so uh tantri sex is one
meditation is another Flow State pickle
ball Runners High working out sometimes
video games so when I work with Esports
professionals I try to teach them how to
enter the Flow State and become one with
the game and they know what I'm talking
about and that's when you see these
players who enter the state where they
are literally like seeing the future and
it's like they know exactly what's going
to happen on the map they know exactly
where these people are going to be and
if you're on on the opposite team when
someone is like the god of the video
game it feels like you're playing
against someone who's super human
because they are they've transcended
like basic human functioning so is that
your biggest takeaway going to India was
was simply the point of focus leading to
happiness that's a very core fundamental
it may be the biggest takeaway um i'
have to think about that a little bit
but I would say the first thing that I
learned that I really fell in love with
is like this was a course in myself so
we formally study mathematics we
formally study you know all kinds of
stuff like even psychology but people
who study psychology don't become better
human beings like you can take a course
on addiction right you can even get a
PhD in addiction it does it literally
does not it's not the same as addiction
treatment so learning something
subjectively and learning something like
informationally are like two different
things and so the coolest thing about
India is this was a course in myself
where do my desires come from how can I
conquer desire like literally how can
you control any part of your mind how
can you can you control desire where
does happiness come from where do my
desires come from like where do my
thoughts come from why can't I wake up
on some days I can wake up at 8: a.m.
and go to Spanish class on other days I
can't what's the difference and this is
what I found so frustrating is no one
could give me that answer and I even
looked at science right and science will
say like circadian rhythm but how do you
fix that like we don't have a course in
the self like literally how does your
digestion work what determines whether
you're constipated or not constipated we
don't teach people these things and so
what I loved in India suddenly I was I I
was in a class that taught me about all
of the things that were [__] my life
which is me I I want to bring up uh
something that I've been thinking about
a lot lately which is the fact that we
have a lot of different ideologues and
experts that try to force their
framework on certain people such as like
you have the Andrew Tates you have other
personal development gurus and stuff
like that and they're all saying like
different things but they're all
promising that these things will make
you happier and fix you right and so
you're taking these data points you want
to apply it because they're coming from
a place of authority right but then
every single time I listen to this I
feel like this data suggests nope this
is wrong you should go with this and
then the only other thing I have to fall
back on that actually is of substance
would be my own personal experience
rather than like looking at what the
data suggests and it was more effective
when I when I look at my own personal
experience and and that's what you're
saying you kind of experienced in this
monk culture in India all these people
have different answers and let's say
that for the sake of fairness or charity
or whatever that there's a varying level
of evidence for each person correct
right but everyone has some kind of
evidence so I think the reason that you
have a thousand different answers a
really great principle for medicine
which is anytime you have a thousand
treatments for something none of them
work think about that for a second why
would that
be probably each one is tailored to a
specific person nope it just doesn't
work so let's think about like do we
have like a treatment like if you get
pneumonia today how many how many what
are the treatment
options pneumonia
yeah whatever medicine they have
antibiotics right youall take
antibiotics it's not like like there's a
thousand things for
sleep right there's like all kinds of
sleep aids and someone's like use this
app and do this meditation and like eat
this diet have chamomile te you can take
medication right because there's a
variability of response but just from
evolutionary standpoint us humans
figured out like oh like before you have
surgery what they do is they take some
Betadine and they swab it all over the
world anywhere you have surgery take
Betadine or some kind of alcohol they
swab some part of your skin anytime you
go to the doctor's office get little
alcohol pad before you get an injection
when something works all of humanity
adopts it stuff like clothing and
cooking food right so any anytime
something really works it is universally
adopted and what's going on with I think
all these people have different ideas I
I didn't know sorry if I'm cutting you
off here but is I think that they're
saying okay this is what maybe worked
for me or this is what the science says
and they're saying it'll work for you
and they're also doing populationbased
medicine right they're saying it'll work
for
everybody like they're talking to the
internet they're not talking to a sample
size of one they're saying if you want
to be rich and successful and famous or
whatever get laid um then this is the
path but that's like fundamentally
different from how I think things work
is that I'm a so I've like studied to
become a monk trained and taught at
Harvard Medical School I'm a clinician
I've done Neuroscience research if you
ask me will this work for you my answer
would be I don't
know I have no idea has it worked for
100 people I've worked with before you
absolutely but one thing you learn when
you start practicing clinical medicine
is just because it works for 100 people
does not mean it works for the 100 and
first like 100% And medicine is going to
teach you that the hard way because you
think it's going to work and that's when
you do that's when you hurt a patient
that's when you fail a patient because
you assumed you knew what was going to
work and so you're like yeah this is
going to work done and that's when when
something doesn't work cuz human beings
are individual right like we're all
unique we all have a unique set of
genetics life
experiences right mental faculties even
there's uniqueness within you that
varies from day to day your caffeine
level will affect your State of
Consciousness will affect the level of
anger that you feel your caffeine
dependence from month to month will
alter all of those things how did being
a monk affect all of these beliefs what
was that like for to be a monk so super
cool yeah so I think um a couple things
happened one is so after my first uh
summer there so I spent three months at
the asham I went to my teachers and I
was like I want to become a monk and so
one of my teachers was brilliant or
they're all brilliant in their own way
and so he's like okay that's great we
we're thrilled Alo that you are very
excited good beta that's very great go
back finish your schooling get doctoral
degree and then come back when you're 30
and we'll take you he didn't say it at
the time but what I Now understand now
is that becoming a monk is about giving
up forsaking life it's about sacrificing
giving up your life okay I don't have
[__] worth giving up there's no
sacrifice so what my teachers told me to
do is go and do rise to the top of what
you can put forth a 100% effort go get a
doctoral degree have something worth
giving up and if you still want to give
it up will'll take you so what does it
mean to be a monk I mean it depends on
the tradition but kind of the the
takeaway that I got with a big lesson
that I learned CU my teachers were
awesome was that being a monk actually
has nothing to do with the external it
has entirely to do with the internal so
if you think about what does the monk do
from day to day right they just meditate
like basically a lot they'll do Karma
Yoga which is like service and other
kinds of things but basically like all
the practices it's all like an internal
Journey like the journey for
enlightenment is not gained by wearing a
fancy Mala and wearing robes and shaving
your head and like that's not I mean
there's plenty of false monks out there
who don't know what's going on right
like it's kind of weird but like once in
a while we'll have like this enlightened
being who like creates a religion
whether it's like Jesus or buha or
whatever but we have thousands and tens
of thousands and hundreds of thousands
of priests and monks who clearly are not
enlightened and so my takeaway and this
is what I thought was beautiful is my
teachers were like you don't actually
need to forsake life and what I sort of
discovered is that you can live life
fully but like it's internally the way
that you respond to things that
determines whether in my opinion you're
really I would use the word
so sadak is someone who is pursuing
spiritual discipline and like pursuing
the road to Enlightenment and it's even
beautiful because it's not a form it's
not a job it's hard to describe so saddu
are not the same things as monks monks
are like formally like you know you take
vows and this kind of stuff but a sadak
is someone who's like going for the
prize which doesn't necessarily mean a
monk so my concern with the pursuing
Enlightenment now I noticed you said
pursuing the road to Enlightenment
rather than pursuing Enlightenment I'm
just going to assume you're talking
about pursuing enlightenment nope you're
saying great great catch okay that
explains a lot okay that so basically my
problem is like I've been like I said
I've had these questions
philosophical uh psychological questions
I've had my entire life and I try to
read these books these personal
development these growth books and I've
read so many of them and they're good
books I love eart toll okay I really
really really do and I found a lot of
value in his books but then I read
something else that spits the contrary
and then I wonder like I said earlier
like which one is right and I think the
problem is I read the one book that
changed I would say my perspective on
all this was sidartha funny enough I'm
sure you've probably read it at some
point in your life I don't remember I
probably read it in like high school or
something it says very similar things to
what you're saying now which is like for
the truth you you look within and it
tells a story of this kid that grows up
and he's supposed to he's the bravman
son if you know what that is so he's
supposed to grow up and be like this
this Legend in his town and very like um
I would say enlightened and then he goes
and that's not satisfying enough for him
so then he goes and he lives with the um
what do you call the the the the people
that oh
athetics I don't know which what what
kind a s c t i c so athetics are like
monks or saddu right that that
relinquish all pleasure yeah everything
in order to aism yes so he does that and
it it doesn't satisfy him it doesn't
fulfill him so then he goes and lives a
life of vanity where he like makes a
bunch of money and becomes a merchant
and does all these things and it doesn't
make him and then he lives with gotama
the um the Buddha for a little bit and
it doesn't satisfy him and then at the
end he just sits by a river under a
mango tree and then he finds like
Enlightenment just looking and listening
to the river and I loved this because I
had read so many personal like
development books and everything and all
these people telling me like this will
make you happy this is how you find
fulfillment Etc you follow this
framework and then in this book it's
just like just sit kind of listen to the
river and I think it was implying
obviously some form of like meditation
or enlightened or heightened
Consciousness right and so I know it's
it's kind of like counter because I'm
still trying to like find something I
would say in order to rather you know
what I mean yeah yeah so so so if I'm
hearing you right so like if someone
listens to that and they're like okay
instead of learning all these things the
right technique to Enlightenment is is
to sit by the river and listen to
yourself right uh well it's not saying
that as like a like a strict framework
but just kind of like look internally
yeah right so then then we can say okay
look internally and then I will become
enlightened mhm right but if I look
internally it's not going to work
so so you're right that there's there's
a lot of counterintuitiveness so let's
explain okay so this is why it was a
great catch that I said I'm pursuing the
road to Enlightenment not Enlightenment
so I'm not going to get in line ain't
going to
happen so let's understand a couple
things so let's talk about budha so one
thing to understand is that this the
road to Enlightenment is not like a good
thing it's like a road of frustration
Despair and like last ditch efforts and
the Hail Marys so if we look at Buddha's
life okay so Buddha was like a king or a
prince so respected powerful married a
beautiful woman had a healthy kid had
everything that he wanted in the world
and in in humans I was going to say in
the west but probably humans we think
that when we're unhappy we think
something else will make me happy so
anytime I feel unhappy I think if this
circumstance in my life was different
then I would be happy there's one really
interesting thing is if you look at all
of the enlightened beings that come out
of like India in India there are for
casts so brahans are the priests these
are the closest to God the teachers and
Experts of meditation below them you
have the chatas which are the Nobles so
the Nobles are like kings right so they
like fight Wars and they eat meat and
they like have sex and stuff like that
brahmans can have sex too and Below them
are the merchants or the vishas and
Below them are the sudras or the
laborers so it's kind of interesting
because if you look at all the
enlightened beings that come out of
India none of them are brahans or maybe
arguably one so everyone who gets
Enlightenment is a king so Buddha was a
prince Krishna which is like a Hindu god
um was a king Ram who's another Hindu
god was a king so we've got like three
enlightened beings and I'm sort of
defining enlightened being as like this
person was so special that like a
religion kind of cropped up around
them I think you can make a very clear
kind of historic and anthropological
argument that these people were
extraordinary like outliers of outliers
that's why religions popped up around so
then the question kind of becomes why
aren't the experts in meditation like
the ones becoming enlightened and the
answer is really fascinating and it's
that what happens to the Kings is they
think okay I'm unhappy and so they go
and satisfy that desire and then they're
unhappy because of something else they
satisfy that desire they satisfy that
desire and eventually they discover that
no amount of satisfaction of my desires
will ever bring me to happiness and then
they're screwed because the formula the
the game that
99.999% of people on the planet in the
history of humanity this is the game
that we've been playing for happiness
yall are unhappy about something you're
unhappy about your haircut if you had
gotten a different haircut then you
would be happier
right I mean happy marginally marginally
I don't know if happy is the right term
but maybe satisfied sure right so so the
the positive affective experience yes
right so like the contentment with life
the lack of frustration the lack of
maybe a tiny amount of shame or whatever
said everything's fair game yeah no by
all means by all means dig in in
agreement yeah go for it all right so so
this is what happens is like these
people attain everything mhm and then
they're like this doesn't work and then
they're screwed and that absolute
despair that nothing is going to work is
actually the fuel that you need to
become enlightened whereas the brahin
they're like oh we're going to be
aesthetic we're going to forsake
material things so what they actually do
is they never there there's a seed of
desire that's always there the Brahman
wakes up in his Hut go goes to the
king's Palace teaches them meditation
for an hour eats a great meal at the
king's Palace goes back home and eats a
simple meal at home before dinner and
then goes to bed right so every day
they're traveling to the king's Palace
they're seeing the the person who has
everything and there's a seed of Desire
there that's left you can get it really
small but you can't really get rid of it
100% or it's very hard to and so the
really interesting thing is that it is
through the gratification of your
desires for some amount of time that
you'll discover that desires are not The
Root of Happiness once you learn that
lesson internally then you can really
start chasing it wow okay so the
interesting thing is that most of the
people that I work with who are like
really on a spiritual path are also
professionally incredibly successful and
what I try to help people do is they'll
come to me and they'll be like you know
let's say moderately successful and
they'll be like I want to learn
spirituality because I'm unhappy I work
in private equity and I've been doing
this for a while and I have anxiety and
like it's causing problems in my
marriage and like I'm a managing
director here and like I don't know like
like I I've I've gotten to where I
wanted to go I took all the right steps
in in life but like I ended up in the
wrong place like I was supposed to be
happy and content and I encourage yall
to just think about the people that you
know who are incredibly professionally
successful right the most successful
people on the world and just based on
what you know about them would you
describe these people as like happy and
content probably no more than the
average person right so and there's data
right so I I get to break the rules that
you know money correlates with happiness
up until a point and I think that it's
hard to be content when security is at
at risk um but in my overwhelming
experience what I find is that the
people who are really on the spiritual
path are the people who start out as
materialistic because that's when you
really get you it's a very powerful
learning to recognize that nothing in
the world will make you happy but you
can't know that until you have
everything in the world you think that
you need to hit like the lowest low to
break to I would say find some form of
not find Enlightenment but like end up
on that road towards Enlightenment and
really start questioning the things that
you've believed probably that you have
to achieve so much to then I think go to
something like that well it's just about
sacrifice right what do you mean losing
things that you thought were valuable
and then getting that reality check of
like you know you need to lose
anything go ahead oh I was saying from
your perspective it seems like when you
achieve so much then it's like what's
the next thing I could achieve I think
that would be Enlightenment at that
point Not Like a Rock Bottom thing but
like okay I've got everything I I need
here more is not going to help that so
what don't I have Enlightenment so I I
think I think youall are both right but
I think the question is the wrong
question and so listen to me okay so
what are youall doing you're saying okay
there's this internal path right and
what are you asking you're saying is
this the circumstance that leads to the
right internal path or is that the
circumstance that leads leads to the
right internal path so so I know it's
sounds kind of weird because I talked
about this shared set of circumstances
as as scientists so by the way when I
first went to India I was super
skeptical about all this kind of stuff
and I'm still skeptical to a certain
degree um but I think that we can look
at data and we can say okay like here
are the core principles but at the same
time I would say that you don't need any
particular circumstance because the work
is actually internal you don't
technically have to have a lot of
desires I mean fulfill all of your
desires you can start right now and just
look at the nature of desire and what
happens when you fulfill a desire does
it lead to happiness right so let me ask
youall a question what do youall like to
eat what's like a favorite Indulgence
In-N-Out In-N-Out Burger okay so like
what is the correlation between what is
like eating in and- out let's go with
in- and- out I think it's a little bit
more indulgent than Pokey this is a
healthy Chad over here um so if we think
about like like what happens when you
eat in and out what happens to your
happiness I would say like it it goes up
when when I'm when I'm eating it and
then afterwards not all of the time but
sometimes I'm like I shouldn't have
ordered three burgers you know and then
I feel a little bit like yeah you know
not the hard decision so so let's even
give you the ideal scenario okay so
let's say that you eat in and out and
you don't have three burgers you have
two yeah two is good okay two is good
and then what happens to that desire
what so you feel happy right because you
had two burgers yeah and then you also
feel proud of yourself because you
didn't overdo it right so there's a
second happiness there well I don't
usually order two burgers so it's I I
couldn't I couldn't put myself in that
situation yeah so so I don't get fries
by the way guys so don't think I'm some
like indulgent person but I get three
burgers okay go ahead um so so then but
what happens over time so now that
you've satisfied your desire yes and
we'll get back to the guilt in a second
because there's a lesson to be learned
there but then are you happy forever no
no I wake up the next morning and
usually you know my stomach doesn't feel
fantastic okay uh and then I would say I
am back to my Baseline okay two days in
3 days in I forget about it okay and
then what happens eventually I get in
and out very good right so the first
thing to understand is now we're in
we're we're stuck y'all think about this
so now your happiness is dependent on
your access to In-N-Out this is the way
that you're structuring your
life right like think about that and
here we are we and you go chase the in-
out because you want the in- and out and
it makes you happy but like hold on a
second now you're like [__] in-
andout is going to determine whether
you're happy on a day or not not to
mention what you said earlier which is a
brilliant Insight by the way that often
times satisfying our desires also comes
with a cost so I'll give you like an
example of let's use In-N-Out but let's
let's space out a little bit so I want
to eat an In-N-Out Burger yeah it's
going to be great I'm excited I'm even
happy before I have it which is
interesting no something to be learned
there so then what happens is I have my
first Burger and then am I
happy I would say you are
satisfied yeah so like I would maybe
happy I I don't know I don't like
happiness is kind of a dangerous word
yeah it's a danger so let's just talk
are you 100% positive no what do you
need to be 100% positive another Burger
absolutely right right so even when you
gratify a desire it grows and you want
it again and then even if you have that
second in an Out burger and then you
have that third in an out burer and now
you've crossed the the bad end of desire
and we've got into like the Shady part
of town where now you feel guilt so if
we really think about it like how much
joy do you really get out of this you're
the first Burger doesn't do it creates
more Cravings the second Burger kind of
feels sort of good because you know your
stomach is like we're done now bro like
your stomach tells you this is enough
but your mind is like [__] no one more
baby let's go I want that Joy the joy
that I used to have oh my God that first
Burger was so delicious and the second
Burger was so delicious I'm chasing the
past and I want to recreate it and so
you have that third burger and then
you're filled with guilt and now it's
like if you really think about it the
anticipation causes you to suffer
even the first Burger doesn't give you
perfect happiness because you want that
second one and that second one as you're
eating it isn't good enough because your
mind is like I want to be hungry again
and have my first Burger that's really
what you want and so the Mind goes on
chasing chasing chasing and the more
that you look at the gratification of
your desires the more you'll realize
that it's you're kind of screwed like no
matter what you do so you don't I think
it helps and we have data to suggest
that there's a certain path that helps
people get to Enlightenment I think that
is a scientist
and at the same time you don't need
it but what if we switch in and out for
something like the gym
something or working you know like how
would this be different because you have
the negative effects of eating too much
in and out but what about doing
something like that that's positive that
you're just as equally obsessed with the
gym excited to go to the gym so I
encourage you all to look at it right so
let's talk about the gym what is your
relationship with happiness in the gym
love going to the gym getting good yeah
so I'm guessing that so when you go to
the gym are you perfectly satisfied when
you leave most of the time usually I
want to do more like I'm I'm like I I
should have pushed myself hard okay
right so there's a slice of unhappiness
and so let's think a little bit about
when you go to the gym what is it that
gives you your contentment I love being
able to zone out like for me put on my
hold on a second this is not this is not
desire this is not the gratification of
Desire this is attaining a state of mind
okay
not the same thing goty okay right
aren't you Desiring that State of Mind
absolutely and what does that do what is
Desiring a state of mind of Peace what
does that create for you happiness right
like no [__] no are you kidding what is
attaining a a state of mind no Desiring
a state of mind oh what does that right
because why does this guy love the gym
so much I'll tell you why he loves the
gym so much because the rest of his
[__] life he can't get it you see
that cuz your mind is so like you love
work and you love the gym because rest
of your mind you're not in that peaceful
state of mind and so you don't like the
other parts of your life you don't like
cleaning the toilet you like going to
the gym zoning out feeling good about
yourself I think I like tasks I like
things to do throughout the day sure
like I feel productive when I do those
things right so I I think that also
feeling productive you're going to I
think you're going to end up sort of in
the same place now if we're talking
about a state of mind then that's that's
kind of my point is that the fulfilling
of desires the reason that desires are
so good is because if you really pay
attention to your process of eating in
and out there's an orgasmic moment
sprinkled in right when you're not doing
the thinking and that that's the thing
is when you take that first bite of in
and out are you the first bite of the
second Burger where everything is
aligned and in that moment you're just
enjoying the burger you're not thinking
about number three you're not regretting
number one you're not thinking about the
gym tomorrow you're not feeling guilty
so if you really look at even the
mechanism of gratifying your desires it
is that when you gratify your desire is
usually for a brief period of time you
enter a particular state of mind so
what's the end goal is it just to be
have extended periods of time in that
state of mind huh because I heard two
questions the end goal right yeah what's
the end goal is just being content
anytime not having anything that you
need the end goal for who for the
average person I have no idea what the
end goal is for the average person okay
but you're suggesting that it's not such
a good thing when I'm on like that that
perfect equilibrium where like the sauce
and the bur the ratio is perfect and I'm
just fulfilled enough like like
achieving that is not a great a good
thing what do you think is achieving
that is that a good thing or a bad thing
perfect probably not a good thing
because it means I'm about to eat a
third burger you know no no no not
allowed so that moment of perfect
equilibrium is exactly what you're
chasing and how does it feel to have
that perfect moment of equilibrium I
think chasing instant gratification
generally speaking broad swipe or Broad
broad Strokes here is not a good thing
like if you want to assign as a general
framework what is good for me what is
bad for me you find something that is
painful immediately but yields rewards
down the road the same way that like
gratification immediately pain down the
road you want to go with the long-term
benefit okay so great point so let's
talk about instant gratification okay so
the problem with instant gratification
is that if we think about it there's
there isn't a the problem with instant
gratification is not in the
gratification it's the price that you
pay for the gratification does that make
sense yes so it's not the state of mind
that's that's the beautiful thing about
instant gratification is when you do
this particular thing for that flash of
OT so I'm an addiction psychiatrist so
like I'll talk to people about using
heroin right and I talk to them and I'm
like this was before I understood
addiction Psychiatry i' be like I don't
understand like heroin is ruining your
life you're like on probation at work
your wife is divorcing you your kids
hate you you mortgaged your house you
took a second mortgage out on your house
in secret and you spent it on heroin
like I don't understand how you just
it's ruining every part of your life I
don't understand why you can't just stop
because everything that you tell me that
you love that's falling apart in your
life is caused by heroin and he's like
bro you don't understand the moment I
use heroin all of the things that are
falling apart in my life go
away that's what fixes the problem it
doesn't create the problem it fixes it
because while I'm high I don't care that
my wife is divorcing me I don't care
that I'm heavily in debt I don't care
that my kids it's the only thing that
makes me feel good right so instant
gratification that Bliss that we can
create chemically is a wonderful thing
if it wasn't a wonderful thing we
wouldn't have addicts the problem is
when you describe instant to it it's the
price that we're willing to pay for
transient states of Happiness eating
that second Burger isn't so much of a
problem and life is meant to be enjoyed
the tricky thing the reason that we the
the key thing that we don't understand
is that thus far since we have not
studied ourselves with even 1% of y'all
yall make a beautiful podcast how many
hours have yall spent analyzing the
podcast that you make what do you think
I don't even know I have no clue many
like 10,000 20,000 30,000 three and a
half years right of doing this I think
at probably my ballpark would be about
10,000 sure right so and and like how
many hours do we spend studying like
what makes us happy and what's the
nature of our desire and what you'll
discover is that the instant
gratification is great like it's that
state of mind it's always the state of
mind so then the question becomes and
this is the problem that we make is
because we haven't studied it we believe
that Des the gratification of Desire is
the is the default way it is the default
way but is the only way to attain that
state of mind we never try to cultivate
the State of Mind independently we never
ask ourselves what are the thousand
different ways that we can get to the
state of mind and gratification of
Desire is just one of them orgasm is
another and orgasm is not the same as
desire right so even if we think about
the sexual act there's the I want to get
laid and then there's the yeah now we're
naked which is a fulfillment of a
certain desire and that's like a state
of like sort of bliss and then there's
the actual state of orgasm which is like
a no mind state if you really pay
attention to it there's like no mental
activity at all postn Clarity and all
the stuff that happens afterward then
your mind kicks into gear right so
you're saying people generally stumble
across something where they get to this
no mind state right like this pure Bliss
equilibrium everything's perfect they
stumble across something like that and
then they continue to pursue that but on
like kind of like an unconscious level
whereas if they had more conscious
thoughts about hey I want to achieve
this state in other areas of life and
they pursue that then it would serve
them better so here's what I think
happens I think human beings do what our
brains are designed to do to do okay
which is that when I feel a certain way
I form an
association so like what happens is you
like how why do you go eat in and out
because your brain is like where is this
happiness coming from it's coming from
the burger so it is a reflexive thing it
is a biological thing it is an
evolutionary thing okay and so then what
happens is it's not it's kind of common
sense right that's why everyone in the
world is chasing desires because it's
actually a default state of like how it
works it's like simple reward circuitry
nucleus cumb stuff like I'm sure you all
have heard about this from other guests
right so when you eat an In-N-Out Burger
you get a spurt of dopamine and the
nucleus accumbens it reinforces Behavior
gives you pleasure you want to do it
again to get that pleasure again but we
also know from Neuroscience remember I'm
allowed to side things y'all aren't is
that sustained activation of the same
circuit doesn't
work right so this is how we develop
tolerance playing the first game of
League of Legends or Dota or valerant or
whatever you want to do is lots of fun
the eighth hour doesn't give you the
same amount of fun
so what people will do is they'll
they'll naturally continue chasing their
desires because that's the only
consistent way that they know how to get
to like a state of peace or contentment
transcend and y'all oh my god do you
guys know how much people Envy you
especially Graham you know why they envy
him this guy is so lucky he feels at
peace when he's working holy
crap everyone on the planet wants to be
like Graham I wish I could love my work
because then I could be super successful
and I wouldn't have to suffer for it I
wish I loved work as much as I love
orgasms or heroin we got to clip that
hear that Josh okay so there's a couple
things I want to I want to dive into
here I would love for you to finish your
story too but while we're talking about
Graham okay so oh I love talking about
myself I have these theories I've known
Graham now don't know how many years
four and a half years four and a half
years okay so fairly well cuz I've live
five it'll be five in March cuz I've
lived with him as well I've lived with
him for eight months here and like no
eight months in LA and then what about a
year here so quite some time right we're
business partners best friends so many
things
right I notice this kind of like lower
vibration undertone of stress
impatience negativity like more neurotic
thinking Etc a lot in him I'd say very
little negative thinking and I Absol and
I absolutely I have the the speaking
Starbucks cup right now okay and I love
him for it right like I I enjoy spending
time with him and everything but I
notice these things and as his friend I
like to provide suggestions on how I
think he can improve his life that's
just what I like to do right you want to
know what you can do to improve his
life don't talk about the look at his
face don't talk about the negative
things about him in public that's number
one
but he oh he doesn't really no I
wouldn't no I speak about Graham
extremely highly and when I'm saying I
notice these like lower vibration things
such as stress and stuff like that this
is me trying to be productive not just
saying this for viewers or I would agree
with them on the stress the negativity
okay it's more this is you know you the
Starbucks cop okay go ahead the star my
bad so anyways and I try to provide
suggestions to him that I think would
make him better off is that like he
really seems happy when he's working but
I'm nervous that a lot of the is about
the ends it's about it's and he says he
attains like this Flow State yes which
which I I agree I can totally understand
that but part of me is concerned that he
continually places his value and worth
and stuff on the ends rather than
enjoying the
process and so I want to know maybe for
Graham
uh what would you say to somebody like
Graham that thinks maybe something will
continually make them happy but they
continually find themselves in this
lower vibrational
State I would never say something to a
person like that
why I would ask them questions so I I
think like there's like the fundamentals
are different here so like you think he
needs help right M and you've diagnosed
some problem because you know him really
well right so you preface this with I've
known you so for so long so you started
out by stacking the deck of like here's
all the EV for why my opinion is
correct right and then you said this is
what I've observed it's clear to me that
you love the guy and that you want to
help him and your heart is in the right
place but if you kind of pay attention
how did he respond to what you said he
combed it absolutely right some of it I
agreed with the stress I agree with sure
so you're self-aware and stuff like that
but affectively like emotionally like he
did not like that bro like yall can go
back and watch the tape or just like
watch there's like a lot of good how you
feel about it I'm indifferent about it I
I think there's a healthy amount of like
back and forth that
Jack totally toally Jack crap for his
haircut so it's like back and forth I
totally agree that there's a lot of
Health here I'm not trying to create a
mountain out of a mole hill but I saw
something called micro Expressions is
and I
just so I I I I got some degree of
discomfort from him the moment you
brought it up like when you were saying
like all this kind of stuff and I'm not
surprised that he pushed back on some of
it but so you want to help someone right
what do you know about them just what
you've observed I mean
clearly I mean a very small portion of
all of the the things in their life the
determinism right in his life that is
led to him making certain judgment calls
and then all I observe is this like I
said a lot of times stress and like
lower vibrational things and from there
I try to understand where is that coming
from okay so Jack so let me ask you how
many things have you said to Graham to
try to help him with this I would I
would say I've brought it up over the
course of a few years several times
right and what effect does it have
so far none but you're a professional so
I like your opinion on it so what I'd
say is that you're a smart guy right
jack you know your stuff bro come on I
think I'm you've read a lot of you've
read a lot of books oh tons of self-help
tons of self-help right you're very
insightful you're very intelligent you
all have a podcast where like literally
the best and brightest Minds present
company accepted come to your podcast
and share with you the wisdom of just
the crazy successes they had and how
they built their life you are very
equipped you say you're not a
professional you may not be a trained
psychotherapist but you know a
lot right I also have a good
understanding okay and despite you
knowing so much and reading so much and
learning so much and knowing this guy so
well everything you've said hasn't
helped stop saying think asking right I
agree with that I agree with that fully
100,000% without a doubt yes I think
people imposing their own beliefs on
what will improve someone's life as I
alluded to earlier is just overall a
negative thing rather than understanding
and understanding for themselves so it's
not about what you're saying is right or
wrong so here's the crazy thing every
single thing that you've told him is
going to help right well it potentially
could have applied but who knows right
ah no so so potentially could if applied
so I'm going to say my statement again
you tell me if you agree or disagree
everything you told him is going to help
if applied so everything you told him is
going to help why isn't it being applied
because he doesn't want to okay how do
we get him to change his mind he
probably has to find out for himself how
do we help him find out for himself
asking questions there we go and look at
what we just did with you what do we do
with me did you pay attention uh you
changed his you asked me questions yes
there you go and now you get it right
okay so this is something my entire life
I have done this where if I see an issue
with someone el else using the term
better off just as a broad stroke I try
to understand where they're coming from
and I see some place where they're
suffering in their life and I try to
assist them and make them better off I
have done this my entire life I try to
fix people right and so I see these
things in Graham and I wonder why people
don't listen to my advice because I've
continued to give advice from my 25
years of existence to people and they
don't apply it right and they are not
better off from my advice so I would say
in the past year maybe to I've kind of
recognized the fact that they do need to
find out for themselves right and there
is Merit suffering and and um and I
would say letting someone suffer or
letting someone but but at what point at
what point do you step in and say
something I know it's super no no Ja
Jack so so here's like once again I
think you're so you're brilliant okay so
let's just like I'm about to say
something that I think could come across
as harsh but I think you're ready for it
so let me just let me just cuddle you
for a bit bit okay so like you care a
lot about other people mhm right and you
read a lot and you learn a lot you've
applied it to your own life you know how
to help help other people you know 100%
that it's going to help him like you
know that like you can give me some
humble [__] answer to make you not sound
arrogant because you're virtue signaling
and you don't want to seem like an
[__] but in your heart of hearts you
know it's going to help him right yes
okay so let's like let's be authentic
with ourselves number one okay okay so
now the question I think the reason the
problem that you're running into is like
so you want to help people yes right and
that drive to help people causes you to
help people and then you want to like
make the world a better place and love
and stuff like that where you need to
start sure you can learn techniques I've
just told you okay you can ask questions
instead of say things and so now like
Jack is like yeah now I'm going to like
ask everybody questions and then I will
help them and I will make the world a
better place because these are the
people that I love and I'm going to help
them have you ever asked yourself why
you want to help all these
people why I because it it's it it
satisfies my selfish desire of being
happy I would say do you know that I
like I like it when somebody makes a
difference I tell someone to open up a
high old savings account I just did this
with a close family friend or not a
family friend a HomeTown friend he did
it and then I texted him I'm like hey
did your interest come in and he's like
yeah I just made x amount of money off
of X amount of money this is amazing I'm
like yes like this is awesome you know
what I mean or I see someone that that's
overweight and I want to help them lose
weight if you really want to fix this
issue yes the key thing that you have to
understand is it's being driven by this
it's not actually about the other person
it's I mean it is about the other person
there's love in there it is satisfying
my own selfish desire yes right so so
then and I I even think the way the word
selfish desire I think is a mental
construction I don't think that's in a
sense what it is I think you've observed
something within yourself and then
you've like read a bunch of books and
you've said this is what's going on
that's not I mean that's a piece of
what's going on so I think if you really
want to get good at this you have to
really dig into where does this desire
because it's like sure it makes your ego
feel good but it's like deeper than
that right
probably yeah like this is like it's a
part of who you
are I would say so yeah right it's not
so satisfying your selfish desires on
the narcissism in ego Spectrum this
isn't
narcissism this is this is you know what
this is this is debt bro what is it debt
you owe these people you think so
absolutely this is karmic debt
baby I interesting okay okay I I I
appreciate the Insight do I agree or do
I disagree I I would say I air more on
the side of disagree because I will do
this plenty of people that I that I
don't feel like I owe oh no no no you ow
that right okay so I know that this is
something that you're going to disagree
with because you don't have a framework
for it and I haven't explained it but if
you want to know what's really going on
this is what I would here's what I think
you will accept Okay the first is that
there's genuine love correct yes there
is some gratification of the ego correct
yes but there's something else there's
like a hunger there's a compulsion which
is not gratification of the ego because
if it was the compulsion was
gratification of the ego we'd see
narcissistic kind of behaviors tell me
I'm beautiful like tell me I'm great
like tell me I'm awesome you don't need
to you don't want them to tell you that
you're good you need to help these
people like you get that
hunger like do you feel that yes yeah
where does that come cuz that ain't ego
bro I would say I do it's part of my
personality to always strive for
fairness this isn't about fairness well
you said it's servicing a debt right uh
sure but I I think that's a mental so
and this is this is where I I agree I do
think that they're a little bit
misaligned yes so here's here's my point
I I know that y'all aren't going to get
this right but this is a conversation
where the my goal here is like a little
bit different which is like I'm going to
plant a seed that ain't going to make
sense okay but as over time if you guys
really want understand I can try to
explain it but over time what you'll
discover so this is another thing about
the East right so like the stuff that I
learned in India a lot of it has
scientific validation but the majority
of it doesn't but I don't think that's
because it's scientifically incorrect I
think that the science is way too slow
because they've been doing this stuff
for thousands of years so they have
thousands of years of development
without scientific validation and
there's all kinds of scientific evidence
overwhelming scientific evidence for the
theory of Karma and we just don't
realize it because we don't think of it
that way so like let's go back 2,000
years
okay um and let's say that okay like so
the theory of karma says that certain
things about this life are determined
for you before you're even born how
radical is
that very is it
true I don't think I would like that
like like hair color is that determined
before you're born before based off of
the genes probably oh interesting so
there is a mechanism that determines
your hair color your height your eye
color your HLA type and the pre
predisposition for autoimmunity all of
these things can are influenced before
you're everborn right right so genetics
is actually a huge scientific support
point for the theory of karma because
they said this for thousands of years
and then we discovered genetics and then
we moved it out of the theory of Karma
and we said this is a whole new thing
but now we it's like duh right genetics
is common sense wasn't Common Sense
4,000 years ago Gregor Mandel hadn't
even been born wouldn't be born for
thousands of years and they sort of
figured out that there are factors in
your life that are essentially cause an
effect so now the question
becomes do all effects in your life have
causes
yes that's your answer what's your yes I
would I would probably agree with that
yeah do all causes have effects yes 100%
this is like Newton's third law I think
right every action has an equal and
opposite reaction so that's like common
sense right so we also have Western
conceptions of this like the butterfly
effect butterfly flaps its wings through
some crazy chain of cause and effect so
now the question becomes at what point
does the chain of cause and effect end
so we're saying that okay hair color is
fair if I slap you across the face there
going to be karmic consequences that's
like completely fine right we're not
talking about that you'll hate me we
mean like just the physics of it so
physics cause and effect is consistent
with Karma so karma is essentially that
actions have consequences that's all it
is and then the thing the yogis they
sort of figured out okay where does this
end where does the kic chain end and
they figured out that cause and effect
is a fundamental principle of the
universe and even the time at which
you're born the fact that you're born in
this year has a Cause right and that
everything in this world is caused by
something else and is it is an insight
into that that is when Karma becomes
kind of mystical and I may have lost
people there but it's like harder to
understand but do yall get what I'm
saying yes right so even the fact that
yall live together for 4 and a half
years has causes has observable causes
but also has subtle causes and this is
where Karma gets into the weird mystical
stuff that is not scientifically valid
at all I think it'll become validated I
think just like new Newtonian mechanics
validated a piece of the theory of Karma
and then genetics validated another
piece of the theory of Karma and then
Bessel Vander kul's work on like trauma
validated another theory of karma that
actions have consequences on a
psychological level which was something
that
200 years ago SCI or even 100 years ago
scientists would have said is completely
ludicrous right that everything is like
behaviorism or it's Neuroscience or it's
the subconscious so like the simple idea
of cause and effect the theory of karma
is nothing but cause and effect and it's
to recognize that every aspect of of
your life has some kind of
cause and then there are certain
learnings that will give you a better
handle on that stuff but what I feel
from you you is that there's an ego
gratification part but that ain't it but
what I think you'll discover and you
should explore this is really look at
like why do you want to do this where is
this hunger and where is this drive
coming from and what you'll discover is
that you can't pinpoint it to any
psychological event in this
life you won't be able to find an
antecedent
cause that explains the power of what
you feel I agree yeah I would agree with
that so when you say in this life do you
mean like a past life or do you it's
been predisposed right it's just just to
give you all a weird example okay so a
couple years ago so I do Psychotherapy
right so in when I in my Psychotherapy
practice like so I'm like I use
evidence-based medicine okay so
sometimes patients come to me for this
stuff but like even when I teach it I'm
very clear with them that this is not
like there's no scientific evidence of
this so with meditation and stuff I'll
say this is what we know scientifically
this is what the Traditions have been
saying for thousands of years this is
what I feel confident about from a
clinical perspective if you're curious
about exploring the rest of it I'm happy
to teach you but just understand that
there's no scientific evidence behind
what I'm going to say next okay so I've
had a couple of patients that have had
like lifelong mental
disorders and the weird thing is that
like you know I had this one patient and
I she's amazing and has taught me so
much and then like so she's had anxiety
her whole life and so I'm teaching a
class somewhere and someone comes up to
me after the class and they're like hey
like I really loved what you taught us
is there any chance you'd be willing to
see my wife like just would you do like
a consult or something and and we we
have a professional relationship I was
like sure and so this person has had
anxiety for many many many many years
and um has also been in like clinical
treatment for many many years and and
she's doing fantastic like is doing
really well um you know is is like a a
well on the track to partner at her
particular firm is professionally
successful has kids is happily married
like everything's great going great
and so after a while so she's like
curious about this sort of spiritual
stuff and we're doing some level of
psychotherapy but she also has other
clinicians that she works with and then
like you know one day she's kind of like
hey can I tell you something I never
told anyone and I was like sure right
like you're therapist you can do that
and she's like I I haven't even told any
of my other therapists this stuff and I
was like oh okay right but not really I
was just like yeah tell me because we
were in a particular space in therapy
where it's not exciting or anything and
then so she starts telling me about like
these memories that she has and like I I
asked her so there's some kind of work
that you can do that's called samsaric
work so these are like the S scars are
like the karmas of the past that sort of
are present in your current life and you
build them in this life too it's we can
talk about that in a second but so she
basically starts telling me about these
like very Vivid memories that she never
had and so what I did is I kind of
treated it like even the fact that she
never had it and her specific experience
was really harrowing and she's like I
asked her like when you feel anxious
like what is the image that comes to
your mind and she says I'm underneath
the floorboards and I know that if I
make a single noise the booted feet on
top will like know that I'm there and I
know it's all over and every day when I
feel anxiety like this is what it is
it's this thing and so this has never
happened to her right so there's like no
evidence that she's actually been in
this situation so I talk to her a little
bit about and I'm kind of shocked by
this and so then I tell her like okay
here's my take on this so if we accept
the theory of karma we would say that
this is uh some scar from a past life
which is present in this life
there's other scientific explanations
maybe you watched a movie when you were
3 years old and the movie was really
scary and it traumatized you some way it
doesn't have to be something mystical
from a past life right there's all kinds
of different explanations here at the
same time what do you feel about like
psychotherapies that trauma right like
what if we work with whatever that
emotional mental energy is and this is
what I think is like unsafe territory in
terms of science is is just sort of
saying like Okay once something exists
in the mind like who knows where it came
from but you can metabolize that thing
you can heal that trauma we do that and
she gets way better so now I'm I come
out of that experience and I start to
wonder a little bit about what do I need
to learn from this right does this mean
that karma is real no actually we have
no evidence that karma is real but we
have one really interesting clinical
hypothesis and that clinical hypothesis
turned into a question that I started
asking patients which is hey do you have
any traumatic experiences that never
happened do you want to talk about those
and oh my God number of people that will
talk about this stuff if you like and
they're like yeah like this is like
crazy but I have these Impressions I
have these memories you know people
think that this is all like some people
think these are repressed memories um
but it's been really interesting
therapeutically and there's actually
some decent actually not decent some
very lowquality evidence if I really
being fair about it that you know this
I'm not the only one there have been
multiple psychotherapists and
psychiatrists that have sort of made
this discovery and have worked with like
memories that don't exist now that's
what we know is that the memory doesn't
exist or that the event did not happen
but there's a big difference and this is
where I I kind of take issue with a lot
of people who are like into Eastern
mysticism because they're not scientists
so they'll say ah see there this memory
doesn't exist therefore it must have
come from a past life that's an
extrapolation I don't think you can make
but going back to you was that two
tangential of an answer no no this is
great so going back to you just my take
on this stuff right so I know what
narcissism looks like I know what
altruistic personality disorder looks
like so altruistic personality disorder
is something when people feel super
depressed unless they're helping someone
else so it's a part of their personality
that my value as a person depends on
whether I'm helping other people or not
I know what all the stuff looks like I
don't get that vibe from you so I think
what's going on with you is something
deeper is what I would call it so
whether you want to call it karmic or
what in my experience I think the best
words to describe it are karmic debt and
I use that term I'm I'm giving you
something that I know you're going to
reject because what are you going to do
after this podcast I'm probably gonna an
Burg and M
Absolut right in that order absolutely
so so this is something that like I'm
planting a seed and you're going to go
explore it because I know that's what
you're going to do and that's all I want
you to do I don't want your acceptance
Here and Now I want to open a part of
you to explore this for yourself if I
want to know about my karmic debt I want
to go and I want to research it I want
to understand it I'm never going to come
to some actual substantial answer
excellent right and then what's going to
happen
next I am going to be left I would say
as an unfilled Cup right absolutely
where so you can't find the answers
outside where are you going to look for
them bro inside sure there you go okay
got it so for these past life
experiences whatever that might be why
do people tend to have the same
recurring fears let's say whether that
be Heights spiders
Darkness uh certain things are all
pretty common is that just an
evolutionary thing that you know afraid
of heights cuz dangerous it it's a great
question and I think it's a question
that the answer which is very scientific
actually has an implication for karma
that a lot of people will reject because
they're actually biased so let's think
through this okay how does a phobia for
a spider develop usually it happens
through a traumatic event right so if we
think about phobias like I had a phobia
of like a kangaroo because I got bit by
a kangaroo when I was in Australia okay
so it's kind of weird phobia right so if
you sort of think about we all know this
like scientific fact that you can rest
as much scientific evidence as you want
that people learn to fear things if we
look at the Neuroscience of fear
development when I have an aversive
stimulus or a painful stimulus I will
learn to fear it so we all fear hot pans
right we don't touch hot pans because we
know that it burns us if someone if I
take a hot pan and we don't think about
it as I fear hot pans because you are
dealing with it in a way that doesn't
evoke fear but if I walk in with a hot
pan and I push it towards you your
response will 100% be fear right so we
actually have overwhelming evidence that
phobias come from
traumas right we have some evidence that
some phobias come from some kind of
genetic impression which by the way what
is that oh it's a memory from a past
life interesting right because that's
what a genetic impression of an inborn
phobia is do you all get that it's like
we have genetic memory which is
literally memories from a past
life so then if we sort of say okay if
if phobias come from psychological
traumas we know that we can track those
back so we can track back let's say 50%
of phobias to psychological traumas
completely scientifically plausible
where do the other 50% come from so one
of two things one is they come from
somewhere else or two is that they come
from a psychological the scientific
principle is the same we just don't know
where the psychological trauma is youall
get that so if you sort of assume the
theory of karma then everything makes
sense this is simply a psychological
Trauma from past life which by the way
through things like epigenetic memory we
also have low quality evidence for so
this is where a lot of people who are
like into the theory of karma will say
like oh like we have this data from
Holocaust Survivors and epigenetic
changes and inherited anxiety and
inherited features of PTSD and stuff
like that and there's some evidence
there but I think it's far from
conclusive so we have some evidence that
memories like literally now we know that
memories can be transmitted between
Generations so now the then the next
question becomes okay so like was it you
right or was it a different human being
and that gets a little bit more
complicated but does that answer your
question it does yeah that's really
interesting a little about certain
mental ailments sure such as like ADHD
and or like autism okay and the reason
why go there are gonna go there Jack so
we kind of brought this up before the
podcast because obviously we take the
online quizzes okay everyone does and I
see this you know disgruntled look in
your face what is your take of these
online quizzes do you think that if it
says hey you should talk to a
professional that you should actually
proceed and talk to a professional part
of me thinks it's a little skewed I
think it was my idea to take the quiz
I'm not sure it was either me or Alex
right doesn't matter but basically as as
a bit of a background we kind of talked
amongst ourselves you're like maybe
we're autistic we do it and I don't mean
this in like a joking way but like I
think all of us have unique traits that
kind of point in that direction and so
we each took a quiz the four of us me
Jack Macy and Alex uh I think on that
quiz if you scored a 25 or higher you're
you're you lean more in that uh
Direction 24 and Below not so much uh
between me Jack and Alex I think I
scored a 24 Alex was like a 23 24 and
Jack was a 25 so what are the chances
that all three of us lean in that
direction that's a question that I don't
have a simple answer to but I have a
complete answer cool it's just not
simple so let's start with your first
question of what do I think about these
quizzes well that depends on the quiz so
some websites for example will use
validated
instruments right so these are things
that these are scientific instruments
that are constructed tested we do things
like factor analysis and stuff like that
we develop these instruments ourselves
at HG because the instruments out there
don't capture what we want to capture
but there's a rigorous scientific
process to determine whether the the
questions I ask you literally correlates
with what I'm trying to measure so one
of the things that we see a lot is like
especially like in the private sector
you have a lot of people who will
develop their own tests like personality
tests or whatever and like all of these
tests like the reason they're very
successful is because they have a lot of
face validity so they're very similar to
astrology in the sense that like why do
people believe in astrology there's it's
a more complex answer but one reason is
because when you when you take the test
it feels right to you therefore you
believe it so the successfulness
especially of a lot of these privately
determined tests or like whatever you
know like websites that people use the
reason that people visit those websites
what they're selecting for is not
scientific validity of test I don't know
if y'all have ever done like a
scientifically valid test but it's a
[__] pain in the ass it's like 300
questions takes 90 minutes and they ask
you the same damn questions over and
over and over again that's what it takes
to get to Scientific validity there are
some versions of that that are a little
bit better like we have things like the
phq9 or the phq2 which are screening
tools for depression so we've got some
decent stuff that's short form
but generally speaking stuff is like
takes hours to really if you really want
to get a faithful representation of what
is going on with someone our science
isn't really that good so should I TR
should we trust these tests or not it
really depends on the test but I think a
lot of people are building tests that
are very
accessible and people like it when they
fill it out which is really what they're
designing the test for that's what
they're shooting for because
scientifically valid tests are really
boring to take
so I'm skeptical of many of those
things second thing but who knows I mean
maybe someone is doing all the factor
analysis and constructing this was like
a 30 uh question quiz that maybe took 10
minutes are all all autistic okay so
statistically let's understand a couple
things about autism autism's on the rise
okay now we don't really know if it's on
the rise because we're detecting it more
or it's actually like increasing in the
percentage of the population so are we
catching cases are we getting better at
catching cases which is certainly true
or is it actually like increasing in the
whole I think both are correct so if you
look at one of the things that
correlates with like autism spectrum uh
diagnosis so like usage of
anti-depressant anti-anxiety medications
during pregnancy correlates with It
ultimately a very small effect but it it
does have an effect um maternal and
paternal age also correlate with autism
so we're all having kids later so I
think that's like there's some data that
suggests that that's possible but I
think the reason that all y'all are
testing High so maybe it's a bad test
who knows right and if we sort of think
about if I'm designing a test that I
want to engage people I'm not going to
give them a yes and I'm not going to
give them a no what I'm going to give
him is a maybe that makes him wonder and
curious and then what I'm going to do I
don't know if there was a CTA or
anything like this sign up for this for
a more advanced test there wasn't no so
unsophisticated webs his fiance scored
very low not yeah not very low but
definitely on the the no so so then the
other thing to understand which I I
think is a key point of the complexity
is I think it's a societ
we are developing features that the ven
diagram between the average person and
someone with autism is like overlapping
more and that's primarily through things
like technology use so if we look at
some of the features of autism it's
things like difficulty with social
connections difficulty with empathy
sometimes difficult a lot of rigid
thinking um a tendency for things like
perseveration and this is absolutely
happening to everyone because of tech so
if we look at like what's happening so
this is something that we help a lot of
people with in our community is there's
a social skills atrophy that's going on
across society and unfortunately text
messaging doesn't isn't just as good as
in-person interaction so if you look at
the brain so our brain
interprets a lot of information from
people right so I'm I'm paying attention
to your facial expressions I'm paying
attention to your body posture I'm
paying attention to all kinds of stuff
and this information is reassuring yall
get that so a lot of the reassuring
information we get socially is like body
language tone eye contact stuff like
that now when I start texting people or
using Discord or whatever the brain is
very efficient so anything it doesn't
use it loses this is why we forget
languages so if I start communicating
with people in the absence of body
language tone and facial expression the
gears in my brain that interpret that
stuff become Rusty and so then what
happens is when I go into a social
situation I'm no longer
reassured by all of this information
because that circuit in my brain is
Rusty which then means I become anxious
and as I become anxious we start
engaging our problem solving circuitry
now I'm thinking is this person like me
not like me oh when should I enter this
conversation these people are talking
back and forth and I have something to
say but should I butt in will they feel
it's bad oh no now that the moment has
passed I now there's a pause in the
conversation but should I go back and
mention this thing that there were
talking about 60 seconds ago or is that
awkward so then what happens is when our
brain does not have kind of empathic
information it uses cognition to make up
the gap which is what it always does
right so when I my left leg is damaged
if I pull the muscle my brain my brain
will naturally favor my right leg to
pick up the slack so what's happening in
our society as a whole is we are
becoming less empathic and less
emotionally aware also because
technology suppresses activity in the
lyic system in the amydala which means
that like literally when I like you know
I'm feeling bad about myself and I look
at cat videos and then the feelings of
Badness go away so we're getting more
emotional like em more emotional
disregulation we're becoming less
empathic we're interpreting social
signals less well because we're using
online communication and this looks
closer and closer to autism right
because these are the deficits in the
brain that people have with autism they
have difficulty with social connections
difficulty with empathy they can just
see things from their own view so we
also have online radicalization and Echo
Chambers which is leading to rigidity
and perseveration which we see take your
political conflict whatever you want
we'll see it there so I think these
things are overlapping and makes it look
like people are autistic but I don't
think we're actually getting autistic I
think we're affecting certain faculties
that are consistent with autism but that
doesn't yall see that's make sense right
it's not autism I think interes it's
like ADHD ADHD kind of if you have ADHD
it mirrors a lot of the traits that an
autistic person would have
right would that would you say it's an
accurate statement or no I it's it's
fair right I wouldn't say that but and I
I think that
ADHD is I'm guessing on the rise or
maybe it's the same thing with autism
where like you know where we have access
to instant gratification all these
things that basically make it so our
expectation or our standards for a
certain level of entertainment value are
so high now that we need to have this
instant gratification in every single
facet of life and I think that could
mirror ADH whether or not it actually
like transforms someone into someone
with ADHD I'm not really sure I don't
know if that's like a possible thing why
does it seem like ADHD is getting so
common it seems like half the kids
growing up is like some form of ADHD
yeah so I I think that's it's a great
question I think it's the same thing as
autism and exactly what what um Jack
Jack said if the mind doesn't use
something it loses it so if we look at
attention span so if you look at like
people say okay like screen time is good
or screen time is bad sometimes parents
you know will ask me we do a lot of work
with parents and they'll ask me like
like what amount of screen time is good
or bad and that's well the issue is
screen time isn't all the same so
there's a a great guy named KL Marcy um
was was a colleague of mine at Harvard
Medical School he started uh an empathy
lab thing where he and he ended up
getting his company got acquired by
neelen so what he would do is he would
hook people up to eegs and like
cardiovascular stuff and stuff like that
he would measure them in a bazillion
different ways and then have him watch
ads and then he would tell companies
this ad is the best based on the EG
activity just brilliant idea so I was
talking to Carl about this and Carl was
kind of pointing out to me that like you
know when you watch Sesame Street and
you're a 5-year-old there is a certain
length of like what you're engaging with
the story is like maybe seven minutes
long so now what's going on is that kids
the moment they get bored with something
so when you're bored with Sesame Street
you have to sit through it and over time
even if you watch Sesame Street every
single day your attention span will
actually increase because you're sort of
forced to pay attention whereas now
what's going on is people have such
simple access to change the thing that
they're viewing so if you look at it if
you give a four-year-old an iPad over
time what'll happen is they won't watch
long form stuff they'll just switch off
of it more and more and more and more
and more which is why if you look at a
lot of these things that are very very
like common for that kids will watch
it's like compilations of super short
form stuff so there'll be an hour of
like a kid that's like looking at 60c
clips and is just like completely
mentally checked out so we absolutely
have a society that is shortening our
attention span we also have a society so
another key feature of ADHD is emotional
disregulation there's even some uh
papers now that are suggesting that you
know there's add which is attention
deficit disorder and there's ADHD which
is attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder and they're even proposing a
third subtype which is like addd with
like emotional disregulation is the
primary feature and so our technology is
regulating our emotions for us right CU
When I feel bad what am I going to do
I'm going to look at cat videos um
there's even a really interesting study
that came out recently that suggested
that 50% of women who use Tinder are
using it to meet psychological needs
completely outside of dating and so
people are super confused it's probably
not just women I don't know why the
study I saw that video you did on that
yeah it was really interesting it's kind
of interesting right so so because
people will wonder like why did this
person match with me in the first place
like you message them and they're like
screw you you suck you're ugly and they
unmatch and like why did you do that
it's because they're fulfilling some
other kind of psychological
need anyway so if we look at what's
going on with Society there's a lot of
stuff that is making our brains more
similar to someone with ADHD now there
that may be independent of probably a my
guess is a rise in ADHD as well uh
because that also correlates with I
think like parental age so as we're
having kids later like we're seeing more
of this stuff that's really interesting
what are the implications of of giving a
kid an iPad had I I go to eat every now
and then and I just see this kid just
just on the it's it's like nothing the
world could be exploding behind them and
they're just fixated on the screen that
can't be good what do y'all think I
think it's terrible I I think it's
rotting away their mind and I think for
kids to have access to to Tik Tok I
think is is a Bad Thing even for myself
I I constantly delete the app to prevent
myself from going on Tik Tok because if
I watch one it's just like five minutes
goes by so fast I'm like what did I just
do so that's so interesting to say
constantly which means you're also
constantly reinstalling well because I
post on Tik Tok so it's it's a bit of a
double Ed because I like to see the
analytics of how my videos do um but
when I'm on there I also like to see
what's going on from a Creator
perspective but I very quickly fall into
the consumer so this has always been
true with parenting where parents will
do things to elicit behaviors in their
children so how do I get my kid to calm
down how do I get my kid to sit how do I
get my kid to
eat and so in the past like we had to do
all kinds of stuff to get our kids to
sit and eat but now we have this
beautiful tool that like Veges them out
and then they become passive and it's
like you know you can just feed them and
they'll be okay so it's a beautiful
emotional regulation technique so like I
don't know if you all so in our case for
example like we're very careful around
technology but you know when when
they're when our kids are on a flight
like we recently took a 30 hour flight
with like a six-year-old and
eight-year-old and so like during that
time we like use technology right
because that's what's going to happen
but even for the first 12 hours of the
flight no Tech and if you think about it
like kids have been flying
internationally all the time and they've
never had technology and they've been
okay on those flights right but now
what's going on is parents are so
terrified of a particular Behavior so
then what happens is they give the iPad
to avoid the behavior but in doing so
what they're actually doing
is reducing the cognitive training that
they're putting their kid through now so
what used to happen when you were a
child and your attention is developing
or even as an adult is you'd have to
force your attention somewhere right so
I don't know if you all like went to
college but like you have to force
yourself to study your mind wanders you
force it to pay attention wanders force
it to pay attention during this podcast
force it to pay
attention and so now what's happening is
we're not forcing kids to do that
anymore so now what's happening is we
have a a a generation of kids who are no
longer taking the stairs to get from
floor one to floor three everyone's
taking the elevator and what it's doing
is Decon conditioning our minds which is
why we see all of the problems that we
see is that our minds are becoming
weaker because we're not pushing them
right everyone's our minds are
constantly being driven around in
mechanized wheelchairs we're taking
elevators we're taking escalators we're
not using our minds we're restraining
them with these external devices that's
what's going on so I think giving your
kid an iPad just giving it to them I
think is a bad idea how could parents
counteract this is it simply taking away
that stimulus from them so we do a ton
of work with parents and here's what
we've learned so it's my belief that
technology is here and here to stay it's
also my belief that when you excessively
restrict a child there's a chance that
they'll build that habit and things will
be okay but there's also a chance that
they will flip out when they get
unfettered access so kids who for
example like never partied and never had
a drink and never were like super like
careful when in high school will
sometimes go to college and they will
just flip the out so our belief is to
teach restraint instead of restriction
and this goes back to like the yoga and
stuff like that right like what did I
learn in India to control your desire to
understand how your mind works right so
this is what we really encourage is it's
not about access to screen time or not
access to screen time it's what are you
teaching your child in relation to the
screen so something that I do with my
kids is I'll ask them they're like first
thing on Saturday morning can we watch
something and I say sure I'll ask him
how much do you want to watch they'll
say a lot okay how much are you having
fun I'll ask him in 30 minutes are you
having fun yes how much fun are you
having so much fun do you all want to
continue yes then I'll ask them after 30
minutes if I try to take it away they'll
Rebel but I ask them are you still
having as much fun no nah they start to
get Wiggly they start to not like it as
much what do you all think about doing
something else no we want to keep
watching because once the dopamine hits
they want to stay then I say okay this
is what we're going to do we're going to
stop now I'm going to take youall to the
playground and then in 30 minutes I'm
going to ask you are you happy you came
to the playground and if the answer is
yes then I'm going to take you to the
playground next time if the answer is no
I'm going to let you watch 30 more
minutes you're in full control right so
a lot of parents will be like you know
irrespective of what the kid says I'm
going to stop it so then what I and the
cool thing is like the kids will learn
and so now they're like their technology
usage is really good they don't get to
use it as much as they want but like
they recognize that there is a
diminishing return on technology us
which is such a great thing to instill
in a kid yeah I like how you're teaching
them how to be a free thinker and make
decisions for themselves because I feel
like school really teaches you you have
to be at this place at this time and do
these things and if you do exactly what
we tell you that's great but then you go
into the real world and you have no idea
what you're supposed to do if someone's
not telling you what to do yeah because
I think that like we were saying earlier
like school like creates factories right
it's like factories for putting out a
certain kind of kid we don't teach
children how they work like we don't
teach them about their mind I mean it's
crazy I'll do you know I'll do like
workshops and stuff at like Fang level
companies and I'll do the literally the
same workshop for like a group of
9-year-olds and it's just as accessible
it's like where does your desire come
from this a whole In-N-Out discussion
you can have that discussion with a
nine-year-old they'll get it just as
well as you did big difference is if you
teach it to them when they're nine like
the whole trajectory of their life
changes that's really interesting
restless leg syndrome RLS is that a mind
thing or is that a is that a body thing
drack is terrible at this just
constantly his leg is like that's not
restless leg syndrome so you have
something called neat which is non
exercise ener something okay so let's
talk about restless leg syndrome so
first of all you ask is it mind or is it
body there's no difference okay so like
what we're sort of learning is that more
and more things are psychosomatic so
even things like physical ailments like
arthritis we think of arthritis is a
physical condition but if you literally
get a phone call and you learn that your
car has been stolen that will affect
your mind right because it hits the Mind
first and then the mind will affect the
brain and the Brain will release
cortisol the cortisol will increase
demarginalization of white blood cells
you'll have 50% more white blood cells
in your bloodstream which means that
your arthritis which is an inflammatory
condition is going to get worse so
arthritis 2 is a psychosomatic condition
what we certainly know about restless
leg syndrome is that it is certainly
quite neurological as opposed to
psychological so we know that for
example Le there's a problem in the
dopamine transmission so dopaminergic
agents are very helpful for restless leg
syndrome the other thing is that when
we're talking about clinical restless
leg leg syndrome we're talking about
people who when they're in bed they kick
their legs so hard that they wake
up so imagine that like imagine you're
you're being attacked by a bear and it's
trying to bite you and you kick it the
force with which you would kick that
bear is the force with which rest people
with restless leg kick so the first
thing is it really makes things hard for
if they're sleeping with anyone else in
the bed the second thing is the force of
the the cake will literally wake them up
so now if this happens 15 every 15
minutes it's very hard to sleep so
restless leg syndrome is like can be a
quite I think it's actually like an
under
appreciated people don't appreciate how
debilitating restless leg syndrome is
it's going to be quite crippling for a
lot of people wow what's going on with
you I mean I have no idea if you have
restless leg syndrome or not but that's
not what I'm hearing what I'm hearing is
that you're fidgety yeah I would say so
yeah so there's a couple things one is
that about 10 to 15% of the calories
that we burn throughout the day for on
average we're going to get to the
variability in a second is from
nonexercise something I forget what it's
called the abbreviation is NE so it's
basically like this MH right um and so
we burn like 10% of our calories just
like fidgeting now in your case what I
would say is that you have a high amount
of Vata so this is like an ayurvedic
concept but you have a lot of wind in
your body so you're you're kind of
fidgety right so we we would say like
even if you look at your hands um your
features are very angular uh you're very
like um conversationally Dynamic right
so like if I have a conversation with
him for three hours there's going to be
a clear chain from A to B to C to D
we're talking about meditation you've
been kind of more running the show than
he has right so you've been talking
about meditation we're talking about
this thing and oh by the way what do you
think about this and if we go for 15
more minutes your mind will jump to
something else so my guess is that you
get bored easily my guess is that you
can dive into something for a long
period of time but then you may like
leave it alone for a little while or
move on to something else so these are
all consistent with Vata which means
that your mind is like the wind it can
blow really hard in One Direction and
it'll blow hard in a different direction
later so it's quite powerful but it's
not necessarily very consistent that
doesn't mean that you can't consistently
have a career it just means that the
more variability that you have within
your career I think the more your you
will have your best mind whereas if I
told you hey you're going to work a
nine-to-five job and you're going to
climb the corporate ladder for a decade
he'd be better at it than you would I
100% agree with that Graham is extremely
good at grinding like putting his nose
to something he's scfa which is earth
and water so stability like low
acceleration high top speed high
acceleration low top speed that's really
fun interesting so so we have this joke
I'm the kite he's the string absolutely
yeah that's our joke he's the rock
you're the kite yeah that makes complete
sense very interesting so the cool thing
about ayurva is that you're able to make
these diagnoses because there's physical
correlations with mental attributes so
if you look at like the veins on the
backs of your hands are going to be more
visible than the veins on the backs of
his hands he has a roundness to his face
you have more angularity so what could
you tell about that about like facial
structure so your face is round his is
more angular your nose is round his is
more angular his ears stick out more my
ears stick out more by the way what do
you think I am is this an angular nose
or a round nose uh angular absolutely
right so I have high vaata too that's
why we're vibing so much and we're like
nice let's talk about this let's talk
about this this is the other thing to
understand about vatas is that the
current Society is very bit the
favorable so the way to success right so
you're talking about like like all these
people who come on and will say this is
the road mhm so our whole society is
biased towards Bas so 9 to5 not 9 to9
which he can pull off
not midnight to 6:00
p.m. twice a month which is probably
what you can do right so like vatas can
work very intensely for a short period
of time gafas can work long periods of
time but everything is fit the oriented
nine to five okay if you look at like
income what correlates with the highest
income over time it's changing jobs
every two to three years so if you stay
in a job for 10 years because you're
like guffa guffa oriented you're going
to get screwed if you change jobs every
six months which you feel like because
it takes you six months to get bored
that's going to screw over vatas so our
our society is generally speaking bit
the favorable that being said a big part
of this stuff if your Vata is
constructing a life that suits your DOA
so like I told y'all I'm this is just
one thing I'm doing today I'm flying out
and I'm going to do do another thing and
then I'm going to work on a book and
then I'm going to do this and I'm going
to do this and I'm going to do this so
what I discovered as Vata is that if I
did one thing I would get exhausted get
exhausted more quickly than my peers but
something miraculous happened if I was
doing four things if I was juggling as
many balls as I could without dropping a
single one my energy levels were through
the loot roof and my productivity is
inhuman right but it's not inhuman it's
just I know how I work and I create an
environment that suits me the problem in
today's society is we always try to
shape the environment I mean sorry we we
always try to shape ourselves to the
environment right so someone looks at
somebody else and says oh that person
has a 4.0 GPA and they go to library
every day I want to turn into that
person I want to be able to go to the
library every day so we spend all of
this time trying to like instead of
discovering who we are we don't even
know all we know is that we want to be
someone else I want to be more confident
I want to have less anxiety I want to
find the answers to life I want to help
other people right like and and as you
look at other people we start adapting
their traits instead what we really need
to do is understand ourselves and then
start to shape the environment around us
so that we don't have to adapt anytime
you adapt you're not operating 100%
because you have a natural inclination
right you have a biological like
circadian rhythm that makes you a
morning person or a night person playing
into that and leaning into that is
actually how you optimize performance so
let's understand a couple things I I
think for you it's not which one is
right what you've got to understand is
there isn't a right there are lots of
Rights okay and the Beautiful Thing is
your mind is so Dynamic that you can
integrate those this is like I don't
know if you've ever played a game where
you like swap stances right like I'm in
like I'm in attack mode I'm in guard
mode I'm in heal mode so that's the way
you need to think about your life it's
not that there's a philosophy that's
correct and a philosophy that's wrong
it's which philosophy do you want to
employ at this moment so you're like
you're changeable you're adaptable so
stop trying to be one thing because bro
how many more books do you need to read
how many more successful people well who
do you think has the answer because you
see the Merit in all of them and you're
trying to bring them all together don't
try to bring them all together that's
his job right he's going to integrate
stuff you get to swap just swap
baby that's that's fascinating okay I we
need to change the topic so it's not so
personalized broke for the audience but
that is I think a lot of people resonate
with that aming but I'd love to talk
about relationships okay how long have
you been married for 12 years how'd you
meet her summer camp and how did you
know that she was going to be your
wife
um I didn't right away so this was it's
kind of an interesting story so like you
know I had known her for a while because
we grew up going to the same summer camp
so I knew who she was but I didn't
really like know her cuz like in summer
camp right like I was in high school she
was in high school but I'm 3 years older
than her so she's like a freshman and
I'm like I'm a junior or senior or
something so we were both counselors and
then the interesting the funny thing is
that I had this was actually the summer
I just finished my time in India so I
came back and I was going to be a
monk and so I I meet this girl who I
find very attractive right but like I've
decided like I'm going to forsake my
life and physical Pleasures are for the
week I'm powerful I'm spiritual I'm
above that no nut November all day long
baby let's go so the interesting thing
is that I had struggled a lot with like
confidence and shame and failing out of
college and all that you asked me like
how were you not terrified it's because
I didn't have a life worth living you
know so I struggled a lot with like
women and ID watched all this stuff from
pickup artists and stuff like that this
was like back when pickup artists were
like before red pill became a thing it's
like favorite favorite topic I love this
I I learned all these like techniques
and stuff and tried them but I just
didn't understand the
fundamentals so I I met this girl and
since dating was out of the question I
could actually talk to her right you
just talk to her because there's nothing
nothing to gain nothing to lose so I'm
just like hey do you want to like you
know you're you're she's coming to we're
going to the same college so she's going
to be a freshman I'm a junior and I was
like I'll show you around right so like
I'll I'll take you out you know like
you're you're moving there for the first
time so like you know I'll show you
where the cool stuff is you like are you
interested in that she said yes so she
insists that I asked her out on a date I
was not asking her out on a date I
didn't think about it as a date I
thought of about it is like I'm 21 she's
18 she's new I know something about this
place like let me just do a nice thing
um so she insists that we were dating
when I didn't think we were dating I was
just you know so um but then we started
dating and then uh yeah I mean so you
asked how how long that's how we met and
then eventually you know I decided the
celibacy thing wasn't going to work out
um and then uh you know found myself
with a girlfriend and it was then that
was confusing for a while in terms of
the whole spirituality thing but then I
sort of realized what I shared with
youall earlier that a monk is not about
having sex or not having sex it's about
the attachment to lust or the freedom
from lust that makes you a monk and this
is why we hear all these stories about
monks and Priests and it's not just
Christians by the way it's like all the
religions right all these people who
have enforced celibacy who don't have
the spiritual training right are the
ones that get into problems and then
they
start usually it's men putting their
dicks where they don't belong
so what I sort of realized is that like
you know it's about conquering lust not
about being celibate so what was the
point you realized you didn't want to be
a monk
anymore in that relationship did you
tell her initially like hey I'm going to
be a monk yeah I think I I think I told
her but she thought we were dating and I
think she also knew me quite well and
she also I think I don't know that she
ever so she's told me many years ago
that you know either you're going to end
up as a Swami which is like a guru like
or or you're going to end up as like
something like what I am now so she saw
a long time ago that like if I had gone
a different route and and you know like
I thought about it like and I ultimately
decided and even now actively try really
hard not to be a spiritual Guru because
it's a whole different thing but um so I
I think she kind of understood our
relationship I think better than I did
for a long time and uh and then
eventually I kind of came around and
then I sort of realized like okay like I
don't have to give up being a monk to
like be in this relationship so being a
monk is more about the identity the
values the belief the intent behind
certain things rather than the actual
action of your well or or why you're
doing yeah so I would say technically
being a monk is not about that but
that's why I use the word sadhak right
so sadak is a spiritual aspirant someone
who is interested in spiritual growth MH
so that's what I would describe myself
as not a monk you're a de facto monk
yeah so I think the most important part
so all monks should be sadhaks and when
monks are not sadhaks is when we run
into problems that's where all the abuse
comes from and the cool thing is you
don't have to be a monk to be a sadok MH
so when you speak to people do you also
speak to people through relationships
and why does it seem like right now I
guess dating seems like a lot harder
than it was maybe 20 years ago so here's
the problem with dating in today's world
so the first problem is that we were
sold a promise that turned out to be a
lie so if you think about dating apps
what is the premise of a dating app
premise of a dating app is that you are
a certain kind of person and in your
Social Circle you have access to only 40
people and you may not match with them
right so there's a perfect person
somewhere out there with you but because
of the bounds of time and space you will
never meet them what we're going to do
is we're going to collect your profile
and we're going to compare it to
billions of other profiles and we will
find that perf perfect person and if we
combine these two people then it'll make
it easier for you to find the perfect
person that's the promise of a dating
app right Fair yeah what's actually
happened is the opposite so now what's
happening is that they say they have all
these perfect people but people are
actually having to go through more and
more and more people before they find
the right one the exact opposite is
happening instead of making the process
easier so you'd have to go through 40
people before you find the one in your
normal life right so if we go back to
like 50 years ago 60 years ago 80 years
ago what was the size of Social Circle
that you would find your mate probably
like somewhere under 300 people for
sure but the bit dating apps said we're
going to make it easier and what they
actually did is make it harder the other
problem is I think a lot of dating apps
um the information that they collect is
something that a lot of people don't
understand the information that they
collect does not correlate necessarily
with relationship success so this is
another good example so if you look at
like let's say if you look at streaming
okay so I can see my viewer count and
like streaming platforms will show me
analytics why do they show you the
analytics that they show
you they want more people yeah they want
more people to watch so you can improve
upon them are the analytics that they
show you the ones that you need to be
looking at to improve I would say watch
avd I would say so so I would say
probably not so the analytics that they
show you is what they can collect you
all get that mhm that's why I like CTR
watch time easy to collect does it
actually correlate with quality like who
the [__] I mean so it correlates with
quality but isn't inform you as to what
to do so this is a big thing if you
think about a dating profile the dating
profile has what we can easily collect
and what we can easily represent it
doesn't contain what creates a
successful relationship do you all get
that yes right so this is a problem with
dating apps is they they have us fill
out all this information but a good
match has nothing to do with hobbies and
interests if youall want to know if you
look at the science of connection and
even the science of sexual activity
there are all kinds of variables there
are four variables that correlate with
sexual activity none of which you can
even detect or matching or connectedness
that you don't find on a datting gap
what are those variables so number one
is a shared emotional experience so
there was a study where they took people
they had people have a first date the
control condition is y'all are going to
meet on a bridge made of stone the
experimental condition is you're going
to meet on a bridge that is a rickety
wooden bridge what they found is that
the level of attractive the attraction
between the two people was way higher on
the rickety Bridge so anytime you can
create a shared emotional experience
between two human beings they bond this
is why people fall in love at rehab so
like rehab is a place where everyone's
like [__] addicted and they're going
through some stuff but boy do they fall
in love at an alarming rate and if any
of y'all have ever worked at rehab or
you know people listening you all know
exactly what I'm talking about because
everyone who is working at the rehab is
paranoid about the patience falling in
love sneaking out [__] all kinds of
stuff we're paranoid about it because it
happens all the time shared emotional
experience is what creates bonds second
thing 90 minutes of activity 90 minutes
of exposure is ideal so as you go past
90 minutes attraction tends to wne
sexuality tends to wne um third thing is
is uh let me think about this what what
do you mean about the 90minut thing
you're saying first date just in general
like if you want to feel connected to
someone you're getting to know someone
oh it's diminishing returns any minute
after yeah so like 90 minutes is like
where things start say if you're dating
it's optimal an hour and a half and then
kind of end it so so there's a group of
people out there who have trouble
getting second dates or we hear this
like feedback a lot which is like there
was no spark so what is the science of
the spark right because what happens
everyone shows up and they're like let's
talk about our interests let's talk
about our Hobbies doesn't correlate at
all with relationships so values over
time will be important for long-term
relationships and will affect things
like conflict so do we want to have kids
do we not want to have kids you know do
we want to be charitable do we want to
accumulate wealth some of that stuff is
really important for long-term stuff and
this is the other confusing thing that a
lot of people don't get is that when
they start dating they're planning for a
long-term relationship but that's not
how we exist as humans we fall in love
first so this is the other thing I've
seen every successful relationship or
almost every successful relationship
I've seen as a psychiatrist and a lot of
people may think okay like if you're a
psychiatrist don't you see bad Rel no
like most people actually have healthy
relationships not everyone comes for
coup's counseling every relationship
I've seen that's successful has at least
one red flag and even that everyone's
like red flag Run for the hills don't
run for the hills because when you have
a red flag early in the relationship you
learn conflict resolution can you manage
conflict with this person right so I had
red flags early in my relationship my
wife had red flags and we worked through
those and wow it turns out that if you
can resolve your red flags that's
actually like a very good prognostic
sign for future relationships but we run
away from
them the other thing that's going on so
there's does that explain the 90 minutes
so yeah the thing about the 90 minutes
is we just know that something about
attractiveness and like how much of a
spark I feel like diminish that after be
mystery like you leave something to be
wanted afterwards yeah so I mean I think
there's all kinds of mechanisms we don't
know why there's kinds of hypothesis but
what we do know is that 90 minutes seems
to be good so shared emotional
experience so I would say like you know
go do something scary together go do
something it doesn't have to be positive
emotion you can actually share negative
emotion it's fine this is why romcoms I
think tend to work well because we're
sort of on the same you know like
emotional wavelength um another thing is
oh yeah the dating has to be free of
hassles so the number one thing not not
number one I just say that yeah
metaphorically but one of the key things
is that when when someone when you ask
people like what makes you want to what
makes you DTF you know it's like this
needs to be hasslefree so another
problem that's happening with dating is
that like dating is not turning into
hasslefree in fact it's becoming the
opposite so I'm selecting for my mate
now right and in order to get this yall
need to pass my tests so dating apps are
increasingly becoming about filtering
and like interviewing they're not it's
not dating anymore it's not like let's
see this goes it's like do you match my
criteria which by the way is created by
the dating apps because they create
criteria they ask you what's your
criteria if you look at the history of
humanity and the whole Animal Kingdom
and mammals and all kinds of no one has
criteria it's like hey like I'm going to
do this dance for you you into it or
you're not into it right all that stuff
is gone from Modern dating which is why
it's so hard because all these criteria
and finding the Perfect Mate and
planning for your life together from day
one like I don't know how to say this
but an early relationship can cannot
withstand the pressures of a long-term
relationship at the first date you can't
do that that's why it crumbles so it
sounds like the Paradox of choice is
making people look for disqualifying
factors rather than qualifying factors
which used to be the way that people saw
dating so there is a paradox of choice
and absolutely people are more
interested in disqualifying and
qualifying but I would say even go one
level deeper the fact that you are
considering a qualifying factor is not
how people fall in
love no one is like
H do you qualify for me or not is this
good enough no everyone's like well [__]
this person is wrong for me but you know
like this is fun and you do stupid [__]
I mean hell my wife started dating
someone who was
celibate like how much more of a red
flag can you get like how stupid like
how stupid is that and there's other red
flags so like since I failed out of
college I like graduated at the age of
23 after 5 years and then what did I do
for the next three years I applied to
medical school so when I was 25 or 26
years old 26 27 and people asked my
girlfriend oh what does your boyfriend
do he applies to medical school that's
literally what I did I got rejected from
120 times red flag after Red Flag after
Red Flag how many people do you know
that would encourage their would
encourage girlfriend to stay with some
dead beat ass guy who's 27 years old has
no money no job prospects no job
experience and has successfully failed
almost failed out of college and has
failed to get into medical school for
two or three years in a row so what did
she see in you she saw me she did not
see the attributes she didn't see the
dating profile and she was [__] right
bro right so like that's the other cool
thing is that like she was right and
like got rejected from 120 times ended
up training and teaching at Harvard
medical school right as well as a list
of other accolades so like when you see
the Human Instead of the attributes of
the human is like when you see
successful relationships how long does
it take for you to see the human I think
it depends on the person but I think
people know very quickly so let me ask
y'all like yall have been together for
four and a half years now right as
business partners we're not together
people know people have
question i'mna I'm use this term care I
don't mean in a sexual Roman way how
long did it take yall to fall in
love um I would say
for after after we after we had
dinner Jack and I got dinner that's off
the rip yeah right he fell in love off
the r well here's the thing to clarify
Jack sent me like eight emails wanting
to do any amount of work and I gave him
a task to do randomly after the eighth
email he nailed the task and as a thank
you I said how about this meet me across
the street from my office and grab some
food he was he was enthusiastic about
like I want more uh what else could I do
and I was like well I have this idea you
down he's like yeah I'm in and so I saw
those qualities so it takes him one
dinner that's amazing he falls in love
quick and hard I take this In fairness I
probably was in love with graham before
that because I was a fan of his content
like it like you know what I mean so
like for me he was like an idol of mine
he made a measurable difference in my
life I got my first credit card because
of him I opened up a high yield savings
account because of him I did all of
these things because of him so I'd say
like probably that and then him like
finally calling me I remember that was
like a huge moment for me you know what
I mean like so so that's a red flag so
y'all fit the criteria okay so number
one is you fell in love he fell in love
and he's got a huge ass red flag that
you didn't know or maybe didn't think
about which is that he was infatuated
with you before he met you yeah but but
but I think that that helps with
dedication that's like
hey idea of gr rather grah as
a that's why it's a red flag right it's
CU you're falling that's what
infatuation is it's falling in love with
an idea instead of a person but my point
to y'all is if you look at successful
relationships I'm telling you every
relationship including yours has one red
flag but I wouldn't see either one of
those as red flags I think falling in
love with the idea of someone is a red
flag and I would say my love grew a lot
deeper clearly clearly you didn't see it
as red flag right I I wouldn't yeah I
mean but now y'all are famous right
y'all are like rich and famous and if
some I know it sounds like y'all are in
relationships romantic relation so like
if someone shows up and is like oh my
God Jack you are so awesome you've
changed my life I love you so much
you're so handsome that haircut is so
fantastic I can't get enough of you tell
me what you want I'll do anything
anything for you well if they like the
haircut that's a so like then that's a
red flot so so right cuz like you kind
of know that this person doesn't know
the real you and and if she asked you on
out on a date would you go I'm assuming
you're heterosexual but would you go uh
yeah dude dep how attractive I but I see
this as like Jack is filtering Jack is
himself on the podcast so people that
come up to him be like I I Vibe with you
I like it let me let me explain he sees
this very differently than I do he says
I need to pick from a pool of our
audience because they know who I am and
I see that as because they know who you
are but because they similar values and
they've watched you enough to be
interested in what you have to offer
that's what I think not because they
know who Jack is but because they Vibe
and and they resonate with what Jack
says I think I have a little less
confidence in that because of the way
that I felt towards you when we
initially met I was an I I I idolize you
and literally I said in the emails I
will do anything that you want me to do
I think I specified I will pick up
Ramsay's cat poop you know what I mean
like I will do I think those are the
qualities I would I would say the same
thing if I looked up to somebody and I
want to work with them I'll do any
anything there's nothing no task I fell
in love with the impact that you made on
my life as far as falling in love with
you as a character I would say it took
me a little bit because you were so
different than anybody I've ever met
before that I had to understand you
before I felt like I could truly love
you you know this is healthy masculinity
right by the way it was infatuation off
the rip and then after understanding who
you are and then me coming to terms with
wow this is somebody I've never met
anybody like this before in my entire
life you're so direct it was hard for me
to because I've never been in like in a
relationship like that where some people
were so upfront um and then finally once
I was like this is just who he is cuz I
saw you treat other people like that
very upfront very blunt then I had to
come to terms with okay do can I accept
this person for them in their entirety
or can I not and I said absolute F yes
without a doubt I can and I think that's
when I fell in love with you so let's
understand a couple things first of all
you were in love with him before you
even met him you were infatuated by him
but once you got to know the real him oh
my God it was so much much better and
you fell so much more in love and if we
look at this right here right so this is
I know we're not talking about a sexual
or romantic relationship but these
qualities you will never find on a
dating app yall get this like listen to
the way that yall are talking about each
other the way that you get to know each
other this is how a real bond forms but
this but the same thing that Jack met me
could be how Jack meets significant
other that's my point that's exactly my
point right so and you're asking what's
wrong with dating the thing is on a
dating app do you get that the
information on a dating app does not
touch what we heard here today and I
don't even think you guys understand
what we heard here today because y'all
were participating but your your
listeners like holy [__] listening to
y'all talk about each other is glorious
it gives me Faith in humanity and I
think that the infatuation that I had
with graham off the rip was not enough
to have a lifelong relationship with him
and once that started to diminish and I
saw these other parts of his character
that I was not used to I had to then
make that decision am I in with this
person or am I not and so that's
completely consistent with I mean I I I
know that everyone's meing about this
but like for real that's completely
consistent with what I'm saying about
relation like romantic relationships too
it can start with a red flag of
infatuation but whether it withstands
the test of time a relationship must
grow and evolve and that's the other
problem with dating apps is everyone's
looking for a finished product so what
people don't understand is I'm trying to
find the right person for a relationship
that is impossible a relationship is
created by two human beings it is it is
not something that you fit someone into
you all get that cuz it's like organic
and just if we listen to y'all's
relationship right and you can think
about the Romantic relationships you've
had you can even think about parental
relationships all relationships grow and
evolve over time and we don't really
think about that at dating apps we're
looking for a finished product that will
slot into my life and even if you find
someone who says they are willing to
slot into your life
you will chances are you will fall out
of love with them over some amount of
time because they're not exciting you in
some way right so sometimes like people
will find exactly what they're looking
for and sometimes it's great and
sometimes it's not but for most of the
people that I've talked to who have
found successful relationships over
dating apps it's like yeah there was
enough to get in the door and what I
discovered was so far beyond what the
app showed me because there's a
fundamental data analytics problem which
is that dating apps cannot collect or
share the actual information that
correlates with a successful
relationship and that even is even more
complex because what a successful
relationship requires evolves over time
relationships need I work with my wife
she's CEO she's my boss right that
sounds very awkward but it works really
well we had kids together me and her
dating a celibate Monk Is version
1.0 right and then it's like not
celibate person and it's loser that's a
different relationship then it's medical
student then it's like faculty at
Harvard Medical School now it's
influencer then she's my boss there's so
many different relationships there that
a real relationship is not something
that you can capture on a piece of
something and they evolve and grow over
time but a good barometer for the health
or
success predictive success of a
relationship would be those four things
that you shared yeah so I don't think I
shared all four so uh connectedness um
sorry um 90 minutes mhm um shared
emotional experience free of daily
hassles and I'm forgetting what the
fourth thing is but there's a fourth and
then what about going from a healthy
relationship then to a healthy marriage
keeping the excitement keeping the spark
keeping the interest they take it you
can't limit it to 90 minutes
anymore um so it's so I'll answer this
question I'm temped to answer the
question same way I answer the last one
is how do y'all keep it
fresh um so now we come full circle to
thric sex no
but um which because it's not sexual in
nature yall can do and it's not it's no
homo I swear no okay but
let's let's understand a couple things
okay so the first thing is to understand
that a relationship evolves over time
which we've already talked about but the
second thing the most important thing
that I think transitions into marriage I
don't know if it's necessarily marriage
or like from the short-term to the
long-term relationship is that early on
you have so much neurochemistry working
in your favor so you're excited by this
person there's novelty there's
attractiveness the sex is new we sort of
know that in a default State the amount
of arousal that you feel with a new
partner is greater than what you feel
with like a partner over time that's in
the default State now a lot of people
will interpret this as like this is a
biological truth the core feature of
human beings that a lot of people who
are like this is the biological truth
the core feature of human beings is that
we are not bound by our biology we're
the only species on the planet planet
that does things that are
biologically we we're not we have
Consciousness and we have the ability to
shape and change our internal
environment now it's possible animals
can do this but we don't have really any
evidence of that we have some evidence
of maybe self-awareness but like a dog
can't wake up one day and decide like I
no longer want to eat this thing like
they're just not capable of that they
can be trained but that internal process
isn't possible so we're not defined by
our biology as human beings and celibacy
is a great example of that right so like
people will be willfully celibate and
it's actually like
works so I think the biggest thing that
is required is you have to understand
that when you first start dating someone
things are going to be easy because the
neurochemistry isn't in your favor
you're going to feel hornier you're
going to feel more excited you're
learning about this person there's going
to be a lot of stuff that's working for
you so the factors work for you and work
for the relationship over time what
starts to happen is you have to start
working you have to start doing the work
so over time what what feels natural
right when youall got together and the
first time you all had dinner and it was
like oh my God this is so natural and
like this is a fit that was made in
heaven and over time that wears out
right and then you all have to start
putting work into maintaining the
relationship so I think this is where a
lot of people fall short is that
relationship feels easy at the beginning
and then people will break up because
it's starting to feel hard this used to
be so easy and that's what happens to
everybody it gets harder for everyone
all the time it's the people who
recognize this is getting hard and this
requires my effort and now I'm going to
have to put intention into it and once
they solve those problems that actually
makes the relationship stronger so when
when things get tough like some people
are like this is not what I signed up
for because it's very different from
what it was early right early on you've
got your honeymoon phase and you're
willing to overlook all the red flags
but at some point case in point of
celibacy right there was a red flag
there was also failure on my part a
second red flag but at some point those
things have to change and I think the
biggest uh problem that I see in modern
relationships is this attitude that like
I don't have to be what someone else
wants me to be like I am perfect the way
that I am if you don't if if you don't
if you can't accept me at my worst you
don't accept you don't deserve me at my
best so there's like this weird attitude
of like Independence and radical
acceptance which I think leads to
toxicity and it's like yeah sorry like
this is just the way I am screw you if
you don't like it you can leave but
where do you find the balance in that
between accepting a person for who they
are and saying ah this is just me versus
knowing if that's something you need to
work on so it's beautiful because I
don't think you need balance I think
what you need is both sure so let's
understand something about acceptance so
people will say like you know so
acceptance is accepting where you
are and growth is about where you want
to go so the pitfalls here are that some
people don't actually accept their
partner so based on so a simple example
is like let's say like body count okay
so whether it's high body count or low
body count like I don't care I'm not
placing a value judge but some people
will say you know you've had like so
this is especially true of like men who
have fewer sexual partners and
especially substantially fewer sexual
partners than uh their female Partners
so they will feel insecure about it and
they won't be able to accept so there's
some kind of like even though they're
dating they're saying accepting things
internally they don't accept and
internally they feel resentment they
feel shame they feel some amount of like
you know like I should have been better
or whatever I I don't know whatever so
if you kind of look at that in that
moment this partner even you're dating
this person you're not accepting
them now that's one thing but change
over time doesn't mean static in fact
it's the opposite so if I'm working with
someone who is let's say an alcoholic
the first step to change is acceptance
as long as you're in denial you can't
accept as long as you're in denial you
can't grow it all right so with
alcoholic synonymous it's like hi my
name is Alo I'm an alcoholic they start
with acceptance so I don't think that
it's a balance between the two I think
one actually leads to the other the
problem is that we've started to think
about acceptance as like cart blanch to
do whatever you want that's not what
acceptance is acceptance is
acknowledgement of the present
circumstances and then once you
acknowledge what the present
circumstances are like in my case like I
realized like holy [__] this girl is not
giving up on me she deserves better
right and there's two things that can
happen when a dude has that thought
number one is oh my God you're going to
leave me right you're going to leave me
and you're going to find someone better
because you deserve better and you don't
deserve me the second is I'm going to
become better I'm going to become what
you deserve and it's when people start
doing that when both parties do that in
the relationship I'm going to be what
you deserve I'm going to grow for the
sake of this relationship I'm going to
get better it's not accept me at my wor
uh if you can't accept me at my worst
you don't deserve me at my best it's
that I'm grateful that you're accepting
me at my worst and you deserve nothing
less than the best 24/7 and that's what
I'm moving towards but you cannot do
that unless you accept that there's a
part of you that's shitty here and now
if we were to draft up a framework for
someone to live like the most meaningful
fulfilling possible life now I know
probably Frameworks are the most
productive thing because you can't
really apply that to everybody um let's
just say this is what my take is and I
want to hear what your thoughts are on
it there are three things which would be
a consistent sleep schedule diet and
exercise I think those three things are
extremely important like those are the
things that you need to nail right and
then after that I think that you can
then go on to like more non-physical
things such as like practicing
acceptance practicing surrender and
relinquishing desire right and then from
there potentially going on to the next
thing which would be crafting your
environment to be
conducive uh or conductive or whatever
for who you are like the things that you
like we discussed earlier in this
conversation would you agree with that
in those steps or would you say that's a
little bit too um rid I don't agree with
those steps and in a few moments I think
you're not going to agree with them
either so bear with me okay so you said
what's the foundation of your thing I
would say physical health so like
exercising uh getting a consistent sleep
schedule and proper nutrition okay and
then what's step two step two would then
be the non-physical things uh which I
think could reasonably follow getting
the the foundation right which would be
uh relinquishing desire relinquishing
desire practicing surrender so let's say
let's take a case okay yeah so and I
apologize if my answer was arrogant but
so let's say that I have trouble
sleeping
mhm how do I take care how do I get a
consistent sleep schedule how do I get a
consistent diet and how do I get
consistent exercise well the reasonable
answer would be you probably need to
exercise more throughout the day to make
yourself tired enough to go to bed at
night yeah but how do I do that exercise
be the other pillar so be like I know
but how do I get myself so like most
people don't exercise regularly don't
sleep a full night and don't eat a
healthy oh so you're saying how do you
get the motivation to start going yeah
right so you're saying those found how
is that Foundation built because we're
presuming that it's not built right so
people aren't do this interesting okay
so I have heard plenty of different
answers to such a question which I think
the most reasonable one would be you
just kind of just have to do it and then
doing it is hard just have to do it is
not a how how do I do it how do you go
to sleep at a regular time and how do
you exercise so you gave me a how for
sleep so you gave me a how for the sleep
is the exercise regularly right setting
standards for yourself so I a lot of
people set standards for myself [__] I
set standards but they don't follow them
why not probably because they have a
history of not following them okay so
where does it
start when the consequence of not
following your standards does not uh
properly is not enough to deter you from
not following your standards in the
first place what is the subjective
experience of that person so let me put
it a different way why doesn't someone
eat healthy let's say I go out to a
restaurant I'm like like I should order
a salad but instead I get a burger right
I think a lot of it has to do with the
consequences not being enough okay so
but then the consequences aren't enough
right so the consequences don't change
right so how am I going to change
that you can impose consequ your own
consequences right but then I guess how
can you follow that yeah so which part
of me imposes
consequences the thinking
brain so here's the crazy thing
relinquishing desire is not what comes
after exercise relinquishing Des is
literally what is required for
exercise okay I don't want to exercise I
want to sit at home and play video games
conquering that desire is literally how
you get to the gym I don't want to go to
bed conquering that desire is how you go
to bed okay to use your own philosophy
against you now how would you then get
the what tools do you use in order to
relinquish desire it's starts with
awareness okay how how do you become
aware you pay attention how do you pay
attention close your eyes okay no right
now what are you aware of your voice
okay I would say my hungry stomach I
would say my knee bouncing that's how
you do
it okay so I have become aware Graham
you do this Too Close Your Eyes what do
you have my eyes been closed okay what
else
uh your voice me sitting in the chair um
paranoia about the
time
um that's what I'm aware of okay so now
we are aware so I want youall to notice
something open your eyes so what
happened to the things that Graham was
aware of over the stretch of the
awareness
exercise so what happened is he became
aware of more and more things and also
subtle and subtler things so it started
with the physical it became the mental
and then if he kept on noticing that
awareness he could even discover the
origins of the paranoia he could
discover all kinds of things as he just
increases his awareness so don't be
distracted no to give yourself time to
yeah I think both of those are true
right so don't be distracted what I
would say is don't be distracted is hard
because you don't control your
distraction what you control is your
intention towards
awareness interesting okay right okay so
it was kind of like a little bit of like
a conscious like meditative State a
little bit in a sense right awareness
awareness Consciousness okay now you
said actually on something
that it doesn't matter if you are
meditating all of the time it matters
the quality of the not meditating but
let's say just say awareness right the
quality of the awareness how do you
increase the quality of your awareness
so I think the biggest mistake that
people make with not increasing the
quality of their awareness is that they
follow a metric for meditation a so they
say I'm going to meditate for 15 minutes
I'm going to install an app on my phone
I'm going to set my timer I'm going to
force myself to sit down and meditate
which means I'm going to observe my
breath but what they're doing is
checking a box they're actually
fulfilling a set of external conditions
which is closing my eyes using the timer
this is meditation meditation is not
that meditation is
awareness so literally it
is being aware right so what are you
aware of you can start with that
question and this is why we have
techniques right so certain techniques
will so I'll give you all like this
technique is going to work maybe better
for you than for you but if you chant oh
you know how to chant Oh no just oh okay
that so om is chanted very simply okay
so I'm going to give you meditation
technique is that cool yeah okay so m is
not M it's a o and so all it is is your
mouth fully open ah and then transition
open it as big as you can uh and then
transition slowly to closed
perfect that is literally what m is and
this is why people are confused because
they think om is om it's not many people
if you look at the more authentic
religious Traditions they will have Au M
so if you chant oh you chant oh seven
times and I want you to notice where you
feel vibration in your body am I
supposed to do this right now no not
just in the future right so people can
do this at home right it's really simple
because you know how to chantome it's
perfect just start with your mouth open
EX
and then close your mouth gradually over
time and you're done and where do I feel
vibrations where do you feel vibrations
right okay so for someone who's a Vata
like you you're curious you want answers
right so if I give you an answer what
are you going to do with it probably
test it and question it and right or
reject it or compare it you're going to
site something else but what about this
but what about this but what about this
that [__] ain't going to work for you I
can give you all the answers it's not
going to be enough you'll enjoy it
intellectually but it's not going to
change no it's not yeah that's funny
yeah you'll you'll get it's intellectual
masturbation is what it is it's like
it's feels good but it is it really is
yeah but no one's going to get pregnant
this way right we really want to change
so then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to tell you and then if you're
motivated you can do it if you're not
motivated you don't have to do it if
you're not motivated you can go read a
thousand books on motivation and find
your motivation you can do whatever the
[__] you want with it if you do this
practice and You observe where the
vibration is you will discover
something and this is how we cultivate
awareness so depending on the person
depending on their temperament depending
on their cognition depending on their
personality this is the other problem
with meditation is that everyone teaches
the same thing because there was a
master and how did the master come up
with the technique the master came up
with the technique because he understood
the stuff or she understood the stuff
and she individualized particular
techniques for their disciples and then
what happens is the disciples learn the
technique and they mechanically teach it
which is why everyone is doing
mindfulness and no one is getting
enlightened so what you do to increase
your
awareness is just do this just observe
and as curiosity for you will help
because now you're looking for something
and if I give you something to look for
then your mind is going to be focused
okay so we have to practice medit
awareness via probably meditation that's
the simplest way the best way but if it
doesn't work for you you don't have to
do it that way there's awareness in
other ways like when you get into that
flow State sure uh yeah okay right okay
uh and then that is what could then spur
hopefully like you you realize
internally that certain things would be
better for you to do and then you don't
have the desire to continue doing the
things that are negative beautiful okay
right and how did you formulate that
because you've done it you realized that
you used to have desires that controlled
you and then you had an internal
Revelation that changed your behavior
it's not willpower it's understanding
and that is why you ask people questions
right yes so another good example of
awareness raising is psychotherapy MH
right so we're asking questions in a
particular way that raise raes someone's
awareness like if you're working with a
narcissist and they don't think they're
not aware of other people's internal
emotional state so by helping them
become aware of
that then they're like oh wow like this
is crazy like we can cure narcissism
like we can cure it it's crazy
permanently absolutely is it just giving
them a set of tools I thought they were
fully atrophied that those parts of
their brain like you cannot connect
those synapses no no no no no no no so
if you look at something like borderline
personality disorder which I think is
very similar to narcissism um narcissism
is more common in men borderline
personality disorder is more common in
women I want to say 95 to 99% of women
with borderline personality disorder are
cured 16 years after
diagnosis 50% two years after by what
real life or by Psychotherapy both so a
lot of people no longer qualify because
as they there's all kinds of nuances to
that so maybe the nature of the the
illness in the first place is that it's
transitory right it's not that it's
Transit it's personality right so and
does personality change over time yeah
100% that's it can you cure
depression the scientific answer
is probably not and we don't know my
instinct is absolutely
for 51 plus percent of people is what
what my gut tells
me I tend to that so my clinical
experience and that's based on clinical
experience so what I mean by that is how
many people have walked into my office
qualifying for a mood disorder like
major depressive disorder and how many
of them after completing treatment are
sustainably able to not qualify for that
disorder without with without ongoing
support so if they complete a course of
psychotherapy for like two years let's
say or medication or whatever and then
like five years later if you measure
them do they have any depressive
episodes
I would say 51% of people 51 plus
percent of people don't and even if you
look at the data on depression the
majority of people who have major
depressive disorder I think the not the
majority but the plurality of them have
only one hearing him debate horos on
this would be insane oh man if we could
who's rosi he's the guy that's coming on
Alex rosi he is a amazing thank you so
much really appreciate it you want to
say where people could find you sure
besides the description um I'm Dr k so I
run an organization called healthy gamer
HG healthy gamer. our YouTube channel is
healthygamergg I think those are like
the best places to find us we're on all
the platforms but YouTube
twitch and website this archaic thing
thank You' all so much all links down
below thank you guys so much for
watching thank you for coming on and
making this trip out here that means a
lot I wish we had an extra hour I wish
we had extra several hours you guys want
to see another one just comment down
below comment down below we'll make it
happen the very end just let us know we
read all the comments and I mean we do a
part two yeah and depending on what
y'all want for part two so the other
thing I'll ask y'all to comment is if
y'all want to yall want to go more solo
and y'all want to dive in we can do that
but that I'll leave up to youall sounds
good thank you guys till next
time